So, hey guys, hey. Hey, Sean. Hey, hi. What city are you in? Everybody's been traveling so much. Where are you at? I'm in the Los Angeles. Will is as well.
嘿，大家好，嘿。嘿，肖恩。嘿，嗨。你在哪个城市？大家最近都在到处飞。你在哪儿呢？我在洛杉矶。威尔也是。
I'm in Los Angeles. I'm in New York. Now, Sean, you've been in New York for a little while, right? Yeah, I'll be home in a month. Wow. In a month. Yeah. You just hopping around, just catching shows, eating dinners,
我在洛杉矶。我在纽约。肖恩，你已经在纽约待了一段时间了，对吧？对，我一个月后就回家。哇。一个月后。对。你就是到处晃晃，看演出，吃晚饭，
and just enjoying? Yeah, just anything I can stuff my face with. Are you doing a... OK? Hmm. Just keep it clean. It's the opening. This is an all new Smart List, dude.
然后纯粹享受？对，就是任何能塞满我嘴巴的东西。你在...好吗？嗯。注意保持干净。这是开场。这可是全新的《精明清单》，老兄。
Smart. List. Smart. List. I ran out of Pop Tarts so this morning I made an English muffin. Oh don't worry we read the internet we saw. You made an English muffin. It was on CNN dude. What'd you stick in all the nooks and crannies? I put some butter and then I made my own cinnamon
精明。清单。精明。清单。我的Pop-Tarts吃完了，所以今天早上我烤了个英式马芬。哦，别担心，我们刷到网上的新闻了。你烤了个英式马芬。这都上CNN了，老兄。你在所有凹洞里抹了什么？我抹了点黄油，然后自己做了肉桂
like mixture, cinnamon sugar mixture. Cinnamon and sugar. By the way, by the way, when you said made your own, meaning you put cinnamon with sugar. Yeah, that's right. And then you start like. Okay, don't talk like you, I went into the lab. Yeah, yeah, no I did.
那种混合物，肉桂糖混合物。肉桂和糖。顺便说一下，顺便说一下，你刚才说自己做的时候，意思是把肉桂跟糖混在一起。对，没错。然后你就开始像。好吧，别说得好像你，我去了实验室一样。对，对，不，我真的去了。
The disposable time you've got right now, Sean Hayes. It's incredible. I am so in fumes. Are you jealous? I've gone back to bed twice already this morning. Oh really? But Jay, you just did a back and forth. You went overseas on a thing and then you came back to LA,
肖恩·海斯，你现在有的是时间挥霍。这太不可思议了。我真是羡慕嫉妒恨。你嫉妒吗？今天早上我已经回床睡了两次了。哦，真的吗？但杰伊，你才刚连轴转了一趟。你刚去海外出差，然后回了洛杉矶，
then you went to New York a couple days, then you came back and then you come back. Why? I don't know. I literally, I almost canceled this today. I almost called in and said that I might have COVID or something, I'm so freaking excited. I can tell you're tired.
接着去纽约待了几天，然后又回来，接着又回来了。为什么？我不知道。说实话，我今天差点把这节目取消了。我差点打电话说我可能得了新冠什么的，我太他妈累了。我看得出来你很累。
But why did you fly back again this weekend? And I know you're going to say, because I want to see the kids and stuff, but come on, man, you got to take care of yourself. You can't do that. Well. Yeah, you can take care of yourself. Because I got to come back, I'm editing.
但你为什么这周末又飞回去了？我知道你想说，因为我想看孩子什么的，但是拜托，老兄，你得照顾好自己。你不能这样。好吧。对，你可以照顾好自己的。因为我得回来，我要剪辑。
I edited yesterday, edit today. It's like, it's a lot. And were you up late editing? No, I went to bed at nine, got up at 4.30. So, okay, you're just tired. But I'm just like, what the fuck? Let Sean and me edit. It's a real boring high class complaint.
我昨天剪辑了，今天也在剪辑。这感觉，真的挺多的。你昨天剪辑到很晚吗？没有，我九点上床，四点半就起了。所以，好吧，你只是累了。但我就觉得，这他妈算什么？让肖恩和我来剪辑。这绝对是个无聊的上流社会抱怨。
No, no, no, but let Sean and I edit. It'll be fun, it'll be so new to you. You'll be like, what the fuck? It's a real boring, high class complaint. No, no, no, but let Sean and I edit. It'll be fun. It'll be so new to you. You'll be like, what the fuck? It's a great new approach. Yeah. Scott and I, I know Jason loves this Kathy and Reed-ous section of the show.
不，不，不，但是让肖恩和我来剪辑。这会很有趣，对你来说也会很新鲜。你会觉得，这他妈算什么？这绝对是个无聊的上流社会抱怨。不，不，不，但是让肖恩和我来剪辑。这会很有趣。对你来说也会很新鲜。你会觉得，这他妈算什么？这真是一个全新的方法。对。我和斯科特，我知道杰森很喜欢节目的这个“凯茜和里达斯”环节。
I do. I've got my coffee here. Okay, good. So Scott and I, we were doing our will and testament, you know, like you have to fill out, you have to do the icky stuff. Oh my God, that sucks. Congratulations, you guys are, it's all going to you.
我确实喜欢。我的咖啡在这儿。好的，很好。所以我和斯科特，我们在弄遗嘱什么的，你知道的，就像你必须填写的那样，你得处理那些让人头疼的破事。哦天哪，太惨了。恭喜你们，这些最后都会归你们。
We're in? Scott is out, yeah. That makes sense. So wait, so, Sean, so you and Scott are going through. Yeah, so we did it, and the guy, it was just, it's stupid, but you know, you have to go in there and you sit in this conference room with the guy, with this estate lawyer, and he goes, I said, I go conference room with a guy, with a state lawyer.
我们进去了吗？斯科特出局了，对。这就合理了。等等，所以，肖恩，你和斯科特正在经历。对，我们去弄了，那个家伙，这真的很蠢，但你知道，你得去那儿，跟那个家伙坐在一间会议室里，跟这个遗产律师，然后他说，我说了，我去了跟一个家伙，跟一个遗产律师的会议室。
And he goes, I said, I go, so wait a minute, let me get this straight. So if I die, and I was doing like before and then after, so I go, if I die, he goes, I'm going to stop you. When you die, go ahead. And I was like, wow. It's coming for you. Yeah.
然后他说，我说了，我去了，所以等一下，让我理清一下。如果我死了，我当时在做那种之前和之后的假设，所以我说，如果我死了，他说，我要打断你。当你死了再说吧。然后我就想，哇。它正向你走来。对。
I'm sorry, when you die, go ahead. And I was like, Jesus. But you know what though? You know what Sean? So I had on what is today, I had last weekend, I had all of our good friend Bradley over here and we were watching some soccer and stuff
对不起，等你死了再说吧。然后我就想，天哪。不过你知道吗？你知道吗，肖恩？所以我上周末，也就是今天是几号来着，上周末，我们的好朋友布拉德利来了我家，我们一起看足球赛什么的，
and he came over and I said, and as you guys know, cause Jason takes fucking pictures of it, so does Paul McAle, of my freezer and my treats that I have in there. Jesus. He sees my treats, Bradley, and I go, oh yeah, that's this like ice cream sandwich
然后他过来了，我说，正如你们知道的，因为杰森他妈的拍了照片，保罗·麦卡尔也拍了，拍了我的冰箱以及我里面存的那些零食。天哪。布拉德利看到了我的零食，我说：“哦对了，这是外面那家叫Round Swamp的店买的冰淇淋三明治，
from this place out here called Round Swamp, and they make chocolate chip cookies with ice cream. Round Swamp, that's what your colon is. Wow. Somebody just woke up. That's so good. I'm so jealous. Somebody just woke up. That's so good. That's what your colon is.
他们用巧克力豆曲奇夹冰淇淋。”Round Swamp，那简直就是你的结肠。哇。有人刚醒过来。太棒了。我太嫉妒了。有人刚醒过来。太棒了。那简直就是你的结肠。
So he goes, are you going to have a little piece of this? I go, hey man, I'm not coming back here. I'm here this one visit, planet Earth. This is a one time visit to this planet. And you're looking to shorten it as much as possible? No, I'm looking to enjoy it as much as possible. I'm not looking for, it doesn't need to be a long shitty time, it just needs to be great.
所以他说：“你要吃一点这个吗？”我说：“嘿，老兄，我可不会再来这儿了。我来地球就这一次。这是我对这个星球的一次性访问。”而你还想尽量缩短它的时间？不，我是想尽情享受它。我可不想，这倒不必是一段漫长而糟糕的时光，它只需要精彩。
Look, for every ice cream sandwich you eat, you just gotta run an extra mile or something. Yeah, there you go. Enjoy it, man, because I don't want the end of the day when we're like, Jay, how was it? And you go, ooh, ooh, ooh, and we go, fuck, we gotta take the tubes out. Why didn't you say we'd take the tubes out? Jay, how was it? And you go, ooh, ooh, ooh. And we go, fuck, we gotta take the tubes out. Why didn't you say we'd take the tubes out?
听着，你每吃一个冰淇淋三明治，就得多跑一英里路什么的。对，就是这样。享受吧，老兄，因为我可不想到了最后一天，我们问：“杰伊，感觉怎么样？”而你发出“哦、哦、哦”的声音，然后我们说：“操，得把管子拔了。”为什么你没说我们会把管子拔了？杰伊，感觉怎么样？而你发出“哦、哦、哦”的声音。然后我们说：“操，得把管子拔了。”为什么你没说我们会把管子拔了？
Jay, how was it? And you go, we're so fucking hungry the whole fucking time. All I can hiss at is, what did you take me around for? All I can hiss at is, do I look puffy? It's gonna say on your tombstone. Puffy, puffy Bateman. Died with zero water retention. JB, can I get it out of you right now?
杰伊，感觉怎么样？而你发出声音，我们他妈一整天都饿得要死。我唯一能嘶嘶地说的是，你带我来这儿干嘛？我唯一能嘶嘶地说的是，我看起来浮肿吗？这会写在你的墓碑上。浮肿的，浮肿的贝特曼。死时体内零水分残留。JB，我现在能从你这儿套出个话吗？
If you happen to pass before me, will you let me put at some point, somewhere on your tombstone, do I look puffy? We were talking about that. Think about it, think about it, think about it. Don't tell me now. We were talking about that in the meeting with the estate lawyer, Will Guy,
如果你碰巧比我先走，你能不能让我在某个时候、在你的墓碑上的某个地方写上：我看起来浮肿吗？我们当时在会议上跟遗产律师讨论过这个，威尔老兄，
and he goes, I said something, came up with that health initiative, like I forget what it's called, where you can pull the plug or not. And he goes, you just gotta make sure if you have a the plug or not. And he goes, you know, you just gotta make sure if you have a feeding tube or something. And I go, I would hook up a feeding tube now. Sure you would.
然后他说，我说了点什么，提到了那种健康倡议，我忘了那叫什么了，就是关于拔掉插头还是保留的。然后他说，你只要确保如果你有插头还是不拔。然后他说，你知道，你只要确保如果你有喂食管什么的。我说，我现在就想接上喂食管。你当然想了。
Sure you would. Sure you would. It's such a shortcut. Sean, how quickly, if we installed, and then we gotta get to our guests, but if we installed, if you came home and in your kitchen, installed and then we got to get to our guests, but if we installed if you came home and in your kitchen There was a trough but it was filled
你当然想了。你当然想了。这可真是个捷径。肖恩，如果我们安装了——然后我们得请嘉宾了——但如果我们安装了，如果你回到家，在你的厨房里——安装了，然后我们得请嘉宾了——但如果我们安装了，如果你回到家，在你的厨房里有一个食槽，但里面装满了
It was filled with like donuts and all the stuff you love and skittles and Hershey's syrup and Hershey's Reese's peanut butter cup and all this stuff that you want to eat and sloppy Joe, how long is the time from the initial disgust and sort of like feeling of resentment and alarm, of the initial seeing it, to you actually getting down. And going to town? Yeah. By the way, a trough of just all your favorite stuff would just be incredible. It'd be incredible.
里面装满了像甜甜圈、所有你最喜欢的零食、彩虹糖、好时糖浆、好时里森花生酱杯、所有你想吃的东西还有糊状三明治，从最初的厌恶、怨恨和警惕，从刚看到它，到你真正趴下去——开始狂吃，这中间隔了多久？大吃一顿？对。顺便说一句，满满一槽你最喜欢的东西，简直太棒了。太棒了。
So I'm saying the gap is pretty short. You'd have a savory trough and a sweet trough, right? I mean, you'd kind of have a lever that would kind of, like a train track, switch the tube, like the little thing that would, yeah. Yeah, that's true. That'd be so good. Sweet trough and a sweet.
所以我是说，这个间隔非常短。你会有个咸味食槽和一个甜味食槽，对吧？我的意思是，你大概会有一个操纵杆，就像火车轨道一样，可以切换管道，就像那种小开关一样，可以，。对，没错。那太棒了。甜味食槽和甜味。
And a trade track switcher. Yeah. Yeah, that's true. That'd be so good. Sweet drop of the state. Trade Trek switcher. Yes. With my mouth just hanging on the bottom. Yeah. That's what I'm saying. Fucking hell, man. I'm going to have Maple draw that.
还有一个铁轨切换器。对，没错。那太棒了。甜味食槽和甜味。铁轨切换器。是的。我的嘴就挂在最下面。对。我就是这个意思。他妈的，老兄。我要让梅普尔画出来。
Please, as just the design of it, the engineering of it. Yeah, let's get some people, let's get some top design. Let's get Johnny Ives on this or somebody. You know what I mean? So, Will, this is all a tee up to your classy guest. Sorry, classy guest who's had to endure all this. Well done. But you know what?
拜托，就当是它的设计、工程学设计。对，我们得找些人，找点顶级设计。让乔纳森·艾维来搞这个或者别的什么。你知道我的意思吗？所以，威尔，这一切都是为了引出你那位高贵的嘉宾。抱歉，这位高贵、不得不忍受这一切的嘉宾。干得好。但你知道吗？
He's a classy guest, but he's also no, no stranger to having a laugh. Oh boy. Because he likes to laugh, but he's also made us laugh. This guy, he's another one of these people, I can't say anything that he's also made us laugh. This guy, he's another one of these people, I can't say anything that he's done because you're immediately gonna know who he is because he's such a part of the fabric of our lives,
他是一位高贵的嘉宾，但他对开玩笑也绝不陌生。哦，天哪。因为他喜欢笑，而且他也让我们笑过。这家伙，他是另外那种人，我不能说他做过什么，因为你马上就会知道他是谁，因为他是我们生活骨肉的一部分，
especially the three of us, because we are such admirers of what he has done over the years and how much he's made us laugh and doing the stuff at the highest level that we're like, oh my God. And I would say this, not doing the stuff at the highest level that we're like, oh my God. And I would say this, not just doing stuff at the highest level, for me potentially doing what I would consider,
尤其是我们三个，因为我们太崇拜他这些年来的成就了，他让我们笑了多少次，把事情做到了最高水平，以至于我们都会想：“哦，天哪。”而且我要说的是，不仅是把事情做到最高水平，对我来说，他可能做出了我所认为的——
and no offense to either of you, the greatest American sitcom of all time, because it just took me through so many, and it just always made me laugh. I got to talk to him about it recently with one of his co-stars. He's done a million different TV shows, but he's the best.
并无冒犯你们俩的意思——有史以来最伟大的美国情景喜剧，因为它带我经历了那么多情绪，而且总是能让我笑出来。我最近刚和他的一个联合主演聊过他。他演过一百万部不同的电视剧，但他绝对是最棒的。
He's, you know, Mayday Malone, Sam Malone, he's also known as Ted Danson. Oh, it's Ted Danson even! Ted Danson! Hello, good morning! What are you doing? Sam Mayday Malone. You guys, with this format, should somehow find a way to have a camera on the guests while you're doing your thing.
他就是，你知道的，梅代·马龙，萨姆·马龙，他也就是特德·丹森。哦，竟然是特德·丹森！特德·丹森！你好，早上好！你在干嘛？萨姆·梅代·马龙。你们几个，用这种形式，真应该想个办法在你们录节目的时候在嘉宾身上安个摄像头。
Because I'm sitting here. As you nod off and keep catching yourself. I'm doing spit takes, I'm putting my hand over my mouth. You are so fucking funny. It's so stupid. Ted Danson, hello. I was just with Jimmy Burroughs last night, and Debbie Burroughs, Scotty and I, at the Hollywood Bowl,
因为我就坐在这儿。当你打瞌睡又猛然惊醒的时候。我在喷水，我把手捂在嘴上。你们他妈的太搞笑了。太蠢了。特德·丹森，你好。我昨晚刚和吉米·伯劳斯以及黛比·伯劳斯、斯科特和我一起在好莱坞碗剧场，
and we were talking about you just last night. And Scotty and I, every like I would say, three or four years, we watched from beginning to the end, no joke, every episode of Cheers, every several years, every episode, over and over. Call me next time you do that. Ted, so Ted, I had the, you know, Ted and I don't really know each other.
我们昨晚还在谈论你呢。斯科特和我，大概每隔，我会说，三四年，就会从头到尾看一遍，不开玩笑，每一集的《干杯酒吧》，每隔几年就看一遍，每一集，一遍又一遍。下次你们干这事时叫上我。特德，所以特德，我——你知道，特德和我其实并不认识。
Ted said three words so far, we're a million. No, but that's good. Trust me, that's very good. So Ted, and you guys, you and Woody invited me on your podcast, which very kindly had me on. And I got to, and I had just watched a bunch of episodes. And so I went crazy on you guys with Cheers stuff. But I want to talk to you about,
特德到目前为止才说了三个字，我们就聊了一百万句。不，但这很好。相信我，这非常好。所以特德，你们，你和伍迪邀请我上了你们的播客，非常感谢你们邀请我。我当时刚看完一堆剧集。所以我对你们的《干杯酒吧》狂热了一番。但我现在想跟你聊聊——
I'm so interested in that moment. So, cheers is such a big thing, especially our generation, we grew up with it. And we weren't little kids, but we loved it. I was in college. What was that moment, that first time you got the script for cheers? I love this more than anything.
我对那个时刻太感兴趣了。所以，《干杯酒吧》是一部影响力巨大的作品，尤其是对我们这一代人来说，我们是看着它长大的。我们当时虽然不是小孩子了，但我们超级喜欢它。我当时在上大学。那个时刻是怎样的，你第一次拿到《干杯酒吧》剧本的时候？我爱死这个了，超过一切。
I'm sorry, I barely heard what you were saying because I loved watching the first question of a podcast as you're trying to formulate, how do we get him talking? Sorry, you're very good at it, Will. No, thank you. You're very good. No, I want to know about Cheers. I want to know about Cheers.
抱歉，我刚才几乎没听清你在说什么，因为我太喜欢看播客的第一个问题了，看着你努力组织语言：我们怎么才能让他开口？抱歉，你很擅长这个，威尔。不，谢谢。你很擅长。不，我想知道关于《干杯酒吧》的事。我想知道关于《干杯酒吧》的事。
So just recap, when did I know the first moment that it was a big- What was the first moment that you laid eyes on the script for Cheers? Wow. I was doing a last second replacement on Taxi. that you laid eyes on the script for Cheers. Wow. I was doing a last second replacement on Taxi. And I was there and Jimmy and Les and Glen had an office down the way at Paramount and they were working on Cheers.
所以简单回顾一下，我是什么时候知道第一个时刻是个大——你第一次看到《干杯酒吧》的剧本是什么时候？哇。我当时正在《出租车》里作最后一秒的替补。你第一次看到《干杯酒吧》的剧本是什么时候？哇。我当时正在《出租车》里作最后一秒的替补。我在那里，吉米、莱斯和格伦在派拉蒙有一间办公室，他们正在制作《干杯酒吧》。
And Jimmy had remembered me from, was it Best of the West? Do you remember that? Western sitcom? That sounds familiar, yeah. Anyway, I auditioned for it, didn't get it, and he remembered me and called me down. And I guess we had a conversation before I got the script and then read it.
吉米还记得我，是因为——是《西部悍将》吗？你还记得那个吗？西部情景喜剧？听起来有点耳熟，对。总之，我去试镜了，没拿到角色，但他记住了我，把我叫了过去。我猜我们在拿到剧本并阅读之前聊过天。
And then I auditioned two or three times and they said to me, okay, don't take another job without letting us know. And I went, oh, so you're saying it's my part? No, just don't, you know, just don't take another job. And I went out the back door and literally up the front door, coming up the stairs to the front door of the office was like every actor in LA.
然后我又试镜了两三次，他们对我说：“好了，在通知我们之前，别接别的工作。”我说：“哦，你的意思是这是我的角色咯？”“不，只是，你知道，别接别的工作。”我从后门走出去，结果字面意义上，正当我要走上办公室正门的台阶时，洛杉矶所有的演员都在那儿。
I think I got cheers because of Shelly Long because she just, she really nailed that part right out. Yeah, brilliant. She was amazing and we got teamed up together when we auditioned. We had to audition as couples. That must have sealed it because you and Shelly had the most incredible sitcom.
我想我能拿到《干杯酒吧》是因为雪莉·朗，因为她一上来就把那个角色演得淋漓尽致。对，太天才了。她太棒了，我们在试镜时被分到了一组。我们必须以情侣档的身份试镜。那一定是一锤定音的关键，因为你和雪莉有着最不可思议的情景喜剧——
Chemistry. Chemistry. Magic. Yeah, really magic, chemistry, but was magic. I mean, Ted, you guys must have felt, that must be one of those things that was instant, right? There was just no, it was in a skateboard. You just had to. You know, it was great.
默契。默契。化学反应。对，真的是化学反应，但那是魔法般的。我是说，特德，你们当时一定有这种感觉，那一定是一拍即合的，对吧？根本没有，那就像滑板一样。你不得不那么做。你知道，那太棒了。
I mean, I am always, always the worst. My first reaction to She Shelley while we were auditioning was, oh, no, no, that's a bad, bad idea. Oh, really? Horrible. Yes, horrible. Why, why, why? I don't know.
我的意思是，我总是，永远是最糟糕的。我试镜时对雪莉的第一反应是：哦，不，不，这真是个糟糕透顶的主意。哦，真的吗？糟糕透了。对，糟糕透了。为什么，为什么，为什么？我不知道。
We were so different. Our styles, our approach, our everything is really different, which is why I think it worked, because it was like this fair fight. It was hard for us sometimes to be in the room together, but when we started working, it was just fantastic, because you'd smack her and she'd smack you back harder. She was just brilliant.
我们太不一样了。我们的风格、方法、一切都截然不同，这也是为什么我觉得它成功了，因为它就像一场势均力敌的较量。有时候我们在同一个房间里都觉得很难熬，但一旦开始工作，那就太棒了，因为你扇她一巴掌，她会更狠地扇回来。她简直太天才了。
Did you always want to do sitcom, like television comedies, because you've made, Ted, you haven't just made a career out of it, comedies, because you've made a, you haven't, Ted, you haven't just made a career out of it, and again, at risk of embarrassing you, you've been at the top of television comedy for like 40 fucking years. To this day. When you were a kid, were you like,
你一直都想拍情景喜剧，比如电视喜剧吗？因为特德，你不仅仅是在喜剧界——而且冒着冒犯你的风险，你已经在电视喜剧界登顶整整他妈40年了。直到今天。当你还是个孩子的时候，你就在想：
I want to do a television comedy, was that the thing that you wanted to do? No, no. I didn't think about it until Stanford and then I discovered acting and I was just, life made sense. I was not an academic. I came from like scientific people in my family,
“我想拍电视喜剧”，那是你一心想做的事吗？不，不。我直到上斯坦福大学之前都没想过这事，然后我发现了表演，一切就都说得通了。我不是个学术型人才。我出身于一个充满科学人才的家庭，
my father, my sister was incredibly bright and I just faked my way through school. I just was over my head. You can't fake your way into Stanford, hang on now. No, you could back then. Really? And I was geographically interesting. I came from Arizona, Flagstaff,
我父亲、我姐姐都聪明绝顶，而我只是在学校里滥竽充数。我完全应付不来。你可没办法靠滥竽充数混进斯坦福，等等。不，你那时候可以。真的吗？而且我的地理背景很有趣。我来自亚利桑那州弗拉格斯夫，
all my friends were Hopi Navajo kids and ranchers, sons and daughters, and galloping here and there, and then went to a private school in Connecticut, Kent School for Boys. And I think I got there for that reason. And then that's kind of interesting. And then truly, I was a horrible student.
我所有的朋友都是霍皮族、纳瓦霍族的孩子以及牧场主的儿子女儿，到处骑马乱跑，然后我去了一所康涅狄格州的私立学校——肯特男校。我想我能进斯坦福就是因为这个原因。这还挺有意思的。而且说实话，我曾是个糟糕透顶的学生。
The first two weeks at Stanford, I was sitting in English, and it's going to sound weird. It was an advanced placement English class because I lucked into it. Because I'm not very bright, I test wonderfully because I don't give a shit. I just kind of wing it and make it a game and have fun. But I was sitting there going,
在斯坦福的前两周，我坐在英语课上，这听起来可能有点怪。那是一个进阶英语班，因为我走了狗屎运才混进去的。因为我不是很聪明，但我考试分数极高，因为我根本不在乎。我只是随便应付，把它当成一场游戏，玩得很开心。但我当时坐在那儿心想：
not only do I not understand what the professor just said in response to this question, this girl sitting next to me said that I have no, and I just pretty much dropped out. Wanted to play basketball nowhere near talented enough. So all my dreams kind of fizzled. And then a little while after that, trying to take some young lady out and have a cup of coffee, and she told me
不仅我听不懂教授对这个问题的回答，而且旁边这个女孩说的话我也完全听不懂，于是我基本上就退学了。我想打篮球，但天赋远远不够。所以我的梦想都破灭了。然后不久之后，为了约一个年轻女孩子出去喝杯咖啡，她告诉我——
about five minutes in because I don't think she was enjoying it, I have an audition I have to go to. And I said, can I come along? And off I went, and to stay in the room, it was like a Bertolt Brecht play, and to stay in the room, they said, well, just do something. And I got up and I heard people laugh.
大概才聊了五分钟，因为我觉得她并不是很享受——“我有个试镜要去。”我说：“我能跟你一起去吗？”然后我就去了，为了留在房间里，那就像是一部贝托尔特·布莱赫特的戏剧，为了留在房间里，他们说：“好吧，你就随便演点什么吧。”我站起来，听到人们笑了。
And it was like, oh, wait a minute. And literally I- It's this drug. Yeah, I took my first acting class and was in some productions and I pulled my station wagon with a sleeping bag in the back and never left the theater until somebody said you should really go back east
那种感觉就像是，哦，等一下。字面意义上，我——这就像毒品一样。对，我上了第一堂表演课，演了几部戏，然后我在旅行车的后备厢里塞了个睡袋，就再也没离开过戏剧界，直到有人对我说：“你真的该去东部进修一下”，于是我去了卡耐基梅隆，事情就是这样。哇。嘿，让我接管一会儿。对，你来吧。威尔·阿奈特，非常感谢你成为我们的第一位嘉宾。你真的帮了我们大忙，我们在收视率等方面都取得了巨大成功。太棒了。
and study, so off I went to Carnegie, but there you are. Wow. Hey, let me take over for a minute. Yeah, you go ahead. Will Arnett, thank you so much for being our first guest. You really did us a good turn, and we did really well in the ratings and all of that. That's so great.
谢谢，谢谢，真的非常感激。那真的很有趣，我太喜欢和你还有伍迪聊天了，我是说，你知道的，再次声明，我一会儿就会不再提《干杯酒吧》了，因为之前提过太多次了。伙计们，看看你们刚才干了什么。但我太爱它了，我还让特德和伍迪听我滔滔不绝地讲我最喜欢的桥段之一，虽然我以前说过，但我要再说一遍，因为我还没在这里说过。
Thank you, thank you, really appreciate it. It was a lot of fun, I love talking to you and Woody so much, I mean, you know, again, I'm going to get off chairs at some point, because I've gotten off on it so many times before. Guys, see what you did there. But I love it so much, and I made Ted and Woody listen to me go on about one of my favorite moments, which I've said before, but I'm going to say it because I haven't said it here.
我最喜欢的时刻，我认为电视史上最搞笑的时刻，就是雪莉·朗说：“你再也见不到我了，你再也见不到黛安·钱伯斯了。这是最后一次，你再也见不到我了。你再也见不到黛安·钱伯斯了。这是最后一次你听到我的消息。”你们猜怎么着，那几个人站在那儿，就像在看戏一样。她发表了盛大的告别演说，走了出去，紧接着你看到门开了，她意识到自己忘了拿外套，你看到她的伸出一只胳膊开始去够衣帽架。
One of my favorite moments, I think the funniest moment for me in TV history for me is this moment where Shelly Long goes, you'll never see me again, you'll never see Diane Chambers ever again. This is the last time you'll never see me again. You'll never see Diane Chambers ever again. This is the last time you'll ever hear from me. And what do you know, those guys are standing there like they're all watching. She makes this grand farewell. She walks out and then all of a sudden you see the door open and she realized she forgot her coat and you see her arm come in and start to reach for the coat rack.
而卡拉就站在那儿，当你看到那只手伸过来时，她只是说——她刚说了“你再也见不到我了”——手伸进来摸索着找衣服，卡拉一把抓住衣帽架，把它往回一拉，刚好够不着。所以那只手伸啊、伸啊、伸啊，最后她整个人摔进了门里，
And Carla's standing there, and as you see the hand come, she just said, you'll never see me again. Hand in, feeling for the coat, and Carla just grabs the coat rack and pulls it just out of reach. So her hand, hand, hand, hand, and then finally she falls through the door,
卡拉说：“嘿，大家快看，是黛安。”我不知道为什么，他妈的，那个笑话的每一个部分，每一个细节，他妈的都完美契合。就是能让我笑出来。因为你知道接下来要发生什么。你简直就像是在惊叹他们是如何在明知结局的情况下，依然能把球稳稳投进篮筐。舞台调度、布景、所有的一切，他妈的太棒了。
and Carla goes, hey everybody everybody look, it's Diane. I don't know why, that fucking, every part of that joke to me, every bit of it just fucking works. It just makes me laugh. Because you know it's coming too. You're sort of like in awe of the way they're still getting it through the hoop, knowing that it's coming. The staging, the thing, all of it, it's fucking amazing.
吉米，你和吉米合作过很多次，肖恩。吉米·伯劳斯太棒了。对，《威尔和格蕾丝》每一集都是他导演的。每一集？每一集。他几乎导演了《干杯酒吧》的每一集，对吧？大概有20集是别人拍的，但基本上是的。他拍了无数集。
Jimmy, you worked with Jimmy a lot, Sean. Jimmy Burroughs is great. Yeah, every single episode of Will and Grace. Every? Every episode. He did almost every episode of Cheers, right? About 20 of them went elsewhere, but yeah. He did tons of them.
但他对喜剧节奏的把控简直疯狂。太不可思议了。我们四个人太幸运了，能在多机位、面对现场观众的模式下工作了这么久。我是说，你们有多怀念这种感觉？对于演员来说，没有比多机位电视节目更好的工作了，我是这么认为的。编剧们挺不容易的，就像我们刚才说的，他们要熬到很晚，但是天哪，
But his sense of physical comedy is insane. Incredible. We four have been so lucky to work so much in a multi-camera, in front of a live audience. I mean, how much do you guys miss it? There's no better job, at least for an actor, than multi-cam television, I think. Writers have it pretty tough, as we said earlier, they're up pretty late, but man,
尤其是拍吉米导演的剧时，你通常周一不用干太多活，摄像走位排练在午饭前就完成了，这真是一份轻松的美差。你们当时是不是拍三周休一周？对。我们是的。对，我是说，这太棒了。这他妈的，简直是史上最棒的。
and especially on a show that Jimmy's directing, where you usually don't work much on Mondays, and Camera Blocking Day is done at lunch, it's a real sweet ride. Did you all do three weeks on, one week off? Yeah. We did. Yeah, I mean, that's amazing. It's the fucking, it's the greatest.
这太不可思议了。我唯一一次生吉米的气是因为，还记得吗肖恩，他想把录制时间从周五晚上改到周二晚上。我特别喜欢周五晚上录完之后，周末就完全没有家庭作业的那种感觉。我一直觉得，如果必须在周二录影，你就会觉得，啊，你满脑子都在想——
It's unbelievable. The only time I ever got mad at Jimmy was, remember Sean, he wanted to switch the tape nights from Friday to Tuesday nights. And I loved the idea that Friday night when you were done, then you had no homework for the weekend. And I always felt when you had to tape on Tuesday, you're like, ah, you were thinking about,
因为你知道，周一你要进行摄像排练，还要搞那些乱七八糟的破事。我可喜欢了。那是当你跟另一个剧组共用拍摄场地时，他们得把布景板转过去面向舞台的另一侧。我喜欢周二晚上。我喜欢周二晚上，因为我可以在
because you know, Monday you got a camera block and do all that shit. I loved it. That's when you're sharing the crew with another show where they got to flip the stands around for the other side of the stage. I like Tuesday nights. I like Tuesday nights because I could
周末把台词背熟。哦。背台词对你来说是一件很难的事吗？是吗？我得承认，我是从一个低级滑稽的笑话起家的，但这能维持生计，比如萨姆·马龙的那些台词。那是制造笑声最有趣、最简单的方式。
soak up the lines over the weekend. Oh. Are lines a tough thing for you to remember? Yeah? I'll have to say, I mean, I started off with a slow dumb joke, which is a great living, Sam Malone's, you know. It's the funniest, easiest way for the laugh.
你演的不是《欢乐一家亲》或者黛安那种语速极快、才华横溢、错综复杂的角色。后来我在迈克·舒尔的《善地》里演了台词最具挑战性的角色。那部剧的格调非常高。但对我和学习台词相比，难的是如何记住它们。所以今年我和小女儿卡特里娜度过了最棒的一段时光。
And you're not doing Frasier or Diane fast, you know, brilliant, complicated. And I've moved on to having some of the most difficult lines to say with Mike Schur in The Good Place. It was so elevated. But it's not hard for me to learn them, it's hard for me to retain them. So this year I had the best time
她会跟我去上班。我再也不用担心台词了，因为她会在那里把台词强行塞进我的脑子里。因为字面意义上，如果摄像机正在换机位，有那15、20分钟的暂停时间什么的，我必须确保自己重新加载台词。你知道的，这样我就不用为它们操心了。
with my youngest daughter, Katrina. She would come to work with me. And I never had to worry about lines because she was there kind of jamming them into my brain. Because literally if the camera's turning around and there's that 15, 20 minute pause or whatever, I need to make sure I reload the lines. You know, so I don't have to worry about them.
免得它们在20分钟内从你脑子里漏出去。所以她会跟你对台词什么的？对，不间断地对。她真的很擅长这个，我们度过了一段非常美好的时光。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。特德，你很有福气能与——
So they don't fall out of your head in 20 minutes. So she'd run lines with you and stuff? Yeah, constantly. She's really good at it, we had a great time. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. Ted, you had the good fortune of working,
你提到了迈克·舒尔，我们大家都认识他并且是好朋友，你曾在《善地》里同他合作，现在你和迈克又有一部新剧了。对。是吗？Netflix，你知道吗？我觉得剧名现在还在改呢。好吧。
you mentioned Mike Schur, whom we all know and are friends with, and you got to work with him on The Good Place, and now you and Mike have a new show. Yeah. Is that right? Netflix, you know what? I think the name is changing as we speak. Okay.
但它的灵感来自智利圣地亚哥的一部纪录片。确实。是的，他们非常搞笑。肖恩刚刚看了一部五集的关于辣椒（chili）的迷你剧——是关于食物辣椒，不是那个国家。他说他是极速狂飙。他说：“然后我吃了一顿五道菜的饭。”他当时看呆了。我确实很喜欢辣椒。
But it came from a documentary out of Chile, out of Santiago, Chile. Sure. Yeah. Yeah, they're very funny. Sean just watched a five part mini series onies on chili on the food not not the country He said he's a speed first. He said and then I had a five-part meal. He was riveted I do love chili
你们现在是怎么录的？这是你们的吗？抱歉，大家现在能看到的不是你们在摄像机前的画面吗？不，这全是音频。那YouTube呢？YouTube？不，没有那玩意儿。不，老兄。好吧，你们俩真是白痴。
When do you guys do it now? Is that you guys? Sorry, are you guys not on camera as far as what people get to see? No, this is all audio. What about YouTube? YouTube? No, not that. No, man. Well, you guys are idiots.
不。你们俩太他妈搞笑了。大家绝对想看到这个。我懂。但那样的话威尔就得把假发戴上了。我是说，看看他。我还得穿鞋。不，你才不用。
No. You are so fucking funny. People want to see this. I hear it. But then Will would have to stick his hair on. I mean, look at him. I have to put my shoes on. No, you don't.
好了，让我重新接管。你在导演什么，杰森？你为什么这么累？你在忙什么？哦，Netflix的一个项目，一部限定剧。叫《黑兔子》。讲的是赛狗。不。
All right, let me take over again. What are you directing, Jason? Why are you so exhausted? What are you working on? Oh, a Netflix thingy, a limited series. It's called Black Rabbit. It's about Dog Tracks. No.
我当时心想：等等，什么？大概一年后就会上映。又是那种忧郁的、黑暗的、会死人的东西——总共8集还是10集？8集，8集。8集就完结，8集拍完走人，对吧？对。
I was like, wait, what? It'll be out in like a year. It's another one of these sort of like moody, dark, people die kind of things that- Is it eight episodes, 10? It's eight, eight. Eight and done, eight and out, right? Yeah.
这难道不让人觉得有点困扰吗？因为我们以前都拍22集、24集。现在他们说只有8集，你就会想，好吧，他们肯定恨死我们了。对。那我这一年剩下的时间该干嘛？或者说他们对我们毫无信心，对吧。嘿，我想回到刚才那个话题，当你提到——
Isn't that slightly disturbing because we all did 22, 24 episodes. And now they say you have eight, you go, well, they must hate us. Right. Well, what am I going to do with the rest of the year? Or I have no faith in us, yeah. Hey, I want to go back to one, when you said,
你当初演戏可以说是心血来潮，纯粹是为了打发学英语等课程之外的空闲时间，我是说，还有打篮球。所以我猜这对你来说是一件非常自然的事，换句话说，你当时并没有用任何习得的表演技巧来让自己纠结，那是后来才有的事。跟我聊聊这个。
so you kinda started with the acting kind of on a lark to fill time unused by your studying English and stuff, I mean, basketball. So I would imagine it was a very natural thing for you to do, in other words, you weren't complicating yourself with any sort of learned technique, that came later. Tell me about that.
所以你当时可能觉得一切非常自然，我们在假装玩游戏嘛，而且你上手非常轻松，然后你才开始学习如何表演，以及那些随之而来的各种表演技巧，你当时怎么消化这些技巧？还是说你觉得“嗯，这些知识挺有用的，
So you probably, it started feeling very natural, well we're just playing pretend, and it came to you very easily, and then you go into learning how to act, and all the technique that comes with those classes, did you have a place for all of that technique, or did you kind of go, ah, that's good to know and everything,
但对我来说感觉很自然”，在你看来表演究竟有多复杂？自从上了表演课之后，你有没有让它变成某种不一样的东西？对，我觉得在卡耐基梅隆的时候有过一个转折点，我很喜欢那里。那是我当时知道的唯一的表演。所以很多其他人来的时候都演过戏或者学过表演，他们对卡耐基梅隆戴有有色眼镜。
but this kind of feels natural to me and how complicated is acting to you? Did you allow for it to become something different once you went into class? Yeah, I think there was a point at Carnegie which I loved. It was the only acting I knew. So a lot of other people had come having acted before or studied before and they had their judgments
我当时就像海绵吸水一样全盘吸收，因为那是我第一次也是唯一一次做这件事。所以对我来说无所谓。然后我去了纽约，吓得要死。从卡耐基梅隆毕业后，你本该直接进入剧团系统。我想那叫TCG（美国剧院协会），就是去全美各地的剧团试镜，结果我们当中没有一个人被录取。我们当时想：“好吧，操，那就一起去纽约吧”，
about Carnegie. I just was lapping it up because it was the first and only time I've ever done it. So it didn't matter to me. Then I went to New York and I was terrified. When you come out of Carnegie, you're supposed to go into the repertory system. I think they're called TCGs, where you go and you audition for all the companies around the country, and none of us got in at all. We went, well, shit, all right, we'll all go to New York,
我们确实也这么做了，但我当时吓得太厉害了，竟然跑去找朱莉亚学院的约翰·豪斯曼，说：“我想入学”，刚刚从卡耐基梅隆毕业的我，居然想重新回到一个系统里，好在纽约保护自己。而他非常温柔地——就像朱莉亚学院是什么随便能进的轻松地方一样。我是说。
and that's what we did, but it terrified me so much that I went to John Houseman at Juilliard and said, I want to enroll, having just graduated from Carnegie, I wanted to be back in a system to protect me in New York somehow. And he very sweetly. Like Juilliard was some sort of easy track there. I mean.
对，但至少在那里面你能受到庇护，你知道的。他非常温柔地说：“好吧，如果你一年后还是这种感觉，再回来吧。”于是我就走了。然后我开始学习，我的确学过各种流派， neighborhood playhouse（邻里剧场），大名鼎鼎的——
Yeah, but at least it was like you were cocooned in, you know, and he very sweetly said, well, if you still feel that way a year from now, come back. But so off I went. And then I studied, I did study names, neighborhood playhouse, famous, famous.
桑迪·梅斯纳尔。桑迪·梅斯纳尔，谢谢。我当了两年的桑迪·梅斯纳尔的学生，学习他那一套表演体系，这绝对是我在表演技巧上破茧而出的关键，因为它不再是关于展示你的技巧或证明你有多优秀，
Sandy Meisner. Sandy Meisner, thank you. I did two years of a Sandy Meisner student teaching a version of that, which really is what I think propelled me out the door acting wise as far as technique, because it stopped being about showing your technique or demonstrating how good you are,
或者说它让我不再自我纠结，而是开始专注于对手演员，这基本上就是表演的全部意义。这很有趣，因为——皮特·乔尔曾在桑迪·梅斯纳尔门下学了两年，他也是我们所有人的共同朋友，还有我们认识的一大群人。但我觉得有趣的是，
or it got me out of my head and started focusing on the other person, which is kind of the whole point of acting. Well, it's interesting because, well, Pete Jowell went went to Sandy Miser for two years to a friend of all of ours, and a bunch of people that we know. But what I found is, what's interesting is,
你去学习戏剧，你上了卡耐基梅隆，你可以去很多地方，全美有很多好学校，但最有价值的是他们开始告诉你当你要去找工作时该怎么做。因为所有那些理论知识确实很棒，但当你真正开始着手
you go and you study theater, you went to Carnegie Mellon, you can go to lots of, there are a lot of great places around the country, but what's the most valuable is when they start talking to you about what to do when you're trying to get a job. Cause all that stuff is really great is sort of great theoretical stuff, but it's so much different when you start to get into
去找工作时，情况就完全不同了。你试着去——指的是怎么试镜以及如何在现场发挥？——嗯，怎么试镜以及如何在当下发挥。你知道的，当你是年轻演员、台词只有几句而且必须立刻表现时，他们可没时间等你走什么狗屁“心路历程”。
trying to get a job. Who do you try to- Meaning like how to audition and how to like- Well, how to audition and how to do it in the moment. You know, they don't have, it's like they don't have time for you to go through your fucking process when you're a young actor and you've only got a couple lines and you gotta show up.
你必须到场然后完美呈现，你知道为什么吗？正如你们所知，因为他们得赶进度。他们必须拍出你的反应或者你那点破事，然后他们得去拍下一场戏。所以他们没时间听你问：“你觉得我的角色会……”，这就好比老兄，闭嘴，把台词演好。
You gotta show up and deliver, you know why? Because as you guys know, because they gotta move on. They gotta get your fucking reaction or whatever your stupid thing is, and they gotta get after this other scene. So they don't have time for you to go like, do you think that my character would, it's like dude, shut up, and deliver.
这才是最可怕的部分，对吧？我是说，当你走进去时你是新人，那有多可怕？我没说错吧？对，你渴望拿高分，但同时你又不能用力过猛，我敢打赌。没错。
And that's the scariest part, right? I mean, when you walk in and you're the new guy, how scary is that? Am I wrong? Yeah, and you want a score, but then yeah, you don't want to overplay it either, I'll bet. Right.
我刚到洛杉矶时真的很幸运，我是说，我在一个外百老汇剧目里当了一年半的替补。我拍过肥皂剧，我什么都干。我去拍商业片当群演也会高兴得要命。我根本不在乎。只要有活干，做什么我都兴奋。甚至仅仅是去上表演课
I was really lucky when I got to LA, which was, I mean, I did, I understudied an off-Broadway show for a year and a half. I did a soap opera and I did, I did anything I could. I would be an extra in a commercial and be just as happy. I didn't care. As long as I was working, doing something, I was thrilled. And even just being in an acting class
都和拿片酬一样令人兴奋。一开始对我来说这根本不重要。后来我到了洛杉矶，我很幸运，因为在洛杉矶，你来就是为了混出名堂。来洛杉矶没有任何别的理由，就是为了红。正值试播集选角季。开干吧。没错，当时我一个朋友
was as exciting as being paid. It didn't matter to me in the beginning. Then when I came to LA, I was lucky enough, because LA, you're just there to make it. There's no other reason to be in LA except to make it. It's pilot season. Let's do it. Right, and I was, a friend of mine,
发起了一个叫“精通”（The Mastery）的项目。那是演员学院举办的，一个为期周末的蜕变式训练。它教的不是表演技巧，而是更侧重于：这是你目前呈现自己的方式。这真的是你想做的吗？因为当你走进房间时，大家看到的就是这样。你肩膀上扛着巨大的“去你妈的”或者诸如此类的情绪。
had started something called The Mastery. It was the Actors Institute, and it was a one weekend kind of transformational. It wasn't a how-to to act, but it was kind of more about, this is how you're presenting yourself. Is that what you want to be doing? Because this is what happens when you walk in the room. You got a big fuck you on your shoulder, or whatever it is.
没错，哦，这太对了。你可能根本不知道自己带着什么情绪走进房间，然后你还在那上面叠加表演技巧什么的。他其实是个——也不能算江湖骗子，好吧，从他跟我说的话来看算是吧——他当时说：“特德，我希望你来担任这个项目的支柱，我们在洛杉矶的这个演员学院，我们打算通过让你教表演来开展。”
Right, oh, that's good. That you don't really know what you're walking in with, and then you put acting on top of that or something. And he actually, kind of a, not a flim flam man, well he is in that he said, Ted, I want you to anchor this project that I'm doing, this Actors Institute here in LA, and we'll do it by you teaching acting.
他硬说服了我必须这么做。每次去上课前我都会吐。这是我经历过最难、最痛苦的事情。而且这不是那种所有学生都成名了的皆大欢喜的结局。我讨厌那段经历，但它确实转移了我对试镜的注意力。相比于教课，去试镜可有趣多了。他教给我的其中一件事就是：
And he convinced me that I had to do this. And I would throw up every night before teaching a class. It was the hardest, most painful thing. And it's not a happy ending like, and all my students became famous or something. I hated it, but it took my mind off of auditioning. It was so much more fun to go audition than teach a class. And one of the things he taught me was,
当你去试镜时，这是一个绝佳的机会，让你去观察自己到底想不想跟这群人合作。你总是急于给他们留下好印象来赢得工作、让他们雇佣你并喜欢你，但问题是你喜欢他们吗？这倒不是说带着傲慢的态度，而是说保持警惕，确保你在审视他们。另一件事是，他们其实非常希望你能表现好。
it's a good chance for you when you go into audition to check out whether or not you wanna be working with those people. You're always trying to impress them to work, to hire you whether or not you wanna be working with those people. You're always trying to impress them to work, to hire you and to like you, but do you like them? And not in an arrogant way, but just heads up, make sure you're looking at them. And the other thing is they want you to be good.
他们无比渴望能选定这个角色。对，我们刚才正聊这个。我刚才就在说这个。你走进房间时，倒不是说真的摆出傲慢的姿态，而是带着一种放松的心态走进去：“我来了。这回肯定特别精彩。我懂你们为这事有多焦头烂额。”
They so want you to be good. They're desperately wanna cast this part. Yeah, we were just talking about that. I was just talking about that. You walk in, not literally and not with arrogance, but you walk in with a relax, I'm here. This is gonna be really good. I get how hard this is for you.
然后你演完你的小片段，最后，无需明说，也不用表现得傲慢，你就说：“谢谢，刚才合作得很开心，但我还有别的事得走了，总之，祝好运，回见。”这样整个人的态度里就完全没有绝望感。性感的冷漠，性感的冷漠。我以前离开时总会说：“祝你们这部剧好运啦。”
And then you do your little scene, and then at the end of it, without literally saying it, without being arrogant, you go, thanks, that was a lot of fun, but I have something else I have to go to, but anyway, good luck, see you later. So that the whole attitude has no desperation to it. Sexy indifference, sexy indifference. I would always say good luck with this, as I leave.
真恶心。哦，太恶心了。等等，他什么意思？他当然会这么说。太恶心了。他当然会这么说。嘿，真恶心。他当然会这么说。嘿伙计们，祝你们这部剧好运啦。太搞笑了。
Gross. Oh, that is disgusting. Wait, what did he mean? Of course he said that. It's so gross. Of course he said that. Hey gross. Of course he said that. Hey guys, good luck with this. That's really funny.
真恶心。哦，太令人作呕了。等等，他是什么意思？他当然会这么说。太恶心了。他当然会这么说。嘿，真恶心。他当然会这么说。嘿，伙计们，祝你们好运。这真的很好笑。
Wait, did I ever tell you guys? Hope it pans out. Yeah. Tell me, Jason, will you tell me, stop me if I said this on the show before, but I once went to, and Will's like, stop. I once went to, I had an audition for, to play like a dental assistant, so I needed a white lab coat, because I was like, I'll dress the part,
等等，我有跟你们说过吗？希望一切顺利。对。告诉我，杰森，你会告诉我，如果我以前在节目里说过这个就打断我，但我曾经去过——而威尔的反应是：打住。我曾经去过，我有一次去试镜，演一个牙医助理，所以我需要一件白大褂，因为我想，我会打扮成那个样子，
right, it was for a commercial. And at night, I was doing sketch comedy in this theater, and that we would kind of rent out at night, but during the day, it was a massive acting class, right? And with like 200 people in the class. And so I was like, oh, on the way to the audition, I'll just run and get my prop, my little white jacket, to go to the commercial audition at the theater.
对吧，那是为一个广告。然后在晚上，我在这个剧院里演小品喜剧，我们晚上会把这里租下来，但白天的时候，这里是一个大型的表演班，对吧？班里大约有200个人。所以我想，在去试镜的路上，我顺便去拿我的道具，我的那件小白衣，去剧院参加广告试镜。
I had no idea it was being used during the day. I walk in and I open the door in front of 200 people and a guy's teaching the class. And I was like, oh my God, oh my God. I was so embarrassed. I was like, I'm so sorry. I do a show here at night and then he was like, it's already too long of a story.
我根本不知道白天这里在上课。我走进去，当着200个人的面推开门，里面有个家伙正在上课。当时我就想，天哪，天哪。我太尴尬了。我说，真的很抱歉。我晚上在这里有个演出，然后他就像是：这故事已经够长的了。
He's like, what do you need? And I was like, I just have to get some. He's like, well, be quick about it, you know, and go get your thing, whatever you need. I was like, it's already too long of a story. He's like, what do you need? And I was like, I just have to get some. He's like, well, be quick about it, you know, and go get your thing, whatever you need. I was like, so sorry. So I go in the back and I'm rustling through and I'm making all this noise. And he's like, can you please be quiet?
他就像是：你到底要什么？我说：我只是得拿点东西。他就像是：行吧，麻利点，你知道的，去拿你的东西，不管你需要什么。我说：这故事已经够长的了。他就像是：你到底要什么？我说：我只是得拿点东西。他就像是：行吧，麻利点，你知道的，去拿你的东西，不管你需要什么。我说：非常抱歉。于是我走到后面，翻箱倒柜的，弄出了好大的动静。然后他说：能请你安静点吗？
I'm teaching a class. And I was like, I'm so sorry. And I keep going and I'm making more noise, more noise. And he goes, are you for real? I go, why don't you act like I'm not here? And I got my stuff when I ran out. They all fucking hated me. Hey Ted, when you were in New York and you're doing all these auditions and stuff,
我在上课呢。我说：真的很抱歉。然后我继续找，弄出更多动静，更多的动静。接着他说：你是认真的吗？我说：你不能当我不存在吗？我拿了东西就跑出去了。他们所有人他妈的都讨厌我。嘿，特德，当你在纽约的时候，你在做所有这些试镜什么的，
I'd imagine you're doing something during the day. Were you waiting tables in sort of a classic way? No, no, I always back to them. Were you selling dope, Ted? Were you selling dope? Yeah, Tom's is bad. Were you selling dope at Dine Bands? What was going on?
我猜你在白天肯定在干点什么。你是在用那种经典的方式端盘子吗？不，不，我总是转回——你在卖毒品吗，特德？你在卖毒品吗？对，汤姆的店很烂。你在Dine Bands卖毒品吗？到底怎么回事？
No, I don't have, that's Woody, sorry. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Woody and the band. Exactly. I am such milk toast. Anyway, I always had enough, back then you could work a day on a commercial
不，我没有，那是伍迪，不好意思。对，对。对。伍迪和乐队。没错。我真是个老好人。不管怎样，我总是攒够了，那时候你拍一天广告
and make a nice whatever to pay your rent, but then the next day you could go collect unemployment. So between working little teeny things, I never actually had to. Fucking unbelievable, you liberal actors sucking up our system, classic. I knew it, you liberal actors, sucking up our system, classic. You knew it, you liberal, you elitist. No, it's fucking, give me a second here,
就能赚一笔不错的报酬来付房租，但第二天你就可以去领失业救济金。所以在这些零零碎碎的工作之间，我其实从来没有——他妈的难以置信，你这个吸干我们体制血的自由派演员，太经典了。我就知道，你这个自由派演员，吸干我们的体制血，太经典了。你早就知道了，你这个自由派，你这个精英。不，这他妈的，给我点时间，
because I want to tee off on the liberal elites. No, it's a great gig, by the way. No, it's a great gig. There's no way you went to Stanford with no plan. What were you going to study at Stanford? Oh, no, I am the guy sitting in the back of the pickup looking behind where the pickup is going, going wow, well look at that, golly.
因为我想痛骂一通自由派精英。不，顺便说一句，这是个好工作。不，这是个好工作。你不可能毫无计划地去斯坦福。你当年在斯坦福打算学什么？哦，不，我就是那个坐在皮卡车后斗里、看着皮卡前进方向后面、觉得哇哦，看那儿，天哪的人。
I never turned around and focused and said I want this. I'm gonna go with this. No aspirations. Until I met Mary, or shortly before I met Mary. I will say that's why you're so chill. You have a really great vibe, I will say that. Yeah, everybody says that. Have you seen my psoriasis commercials?
我从来没有转过身去专注地说我想要这个。我要走这条路。毫无抱负。直到我遇到玛丽，或者说在我遇到玛丽之前不久。我得说这就是为什么你这么淡定。你有一种非常棒的氛围，我得这么说。对，每个人都这么说。你看过我的牛皮癣广告吗？
Yeah. No, no. Hey, listen, I'm a Sky Rizzi guy, so don't get me going. Yeah, yeah, wait. I don't even know, I just see those ads all the time when I'm in this, I see my friend always has this joke. He's like, where is Sky Rizzi family? By the way, can I just say this? I mentioned Pete Giles before.
对。没有，没有。嘿，听着，我是Skyrizi的粉丝，所以别逗我。对，对，等等。我甚至不知道，我只是经常看到这些广告，当我在——我看到我朋友总是有这个笑话。他会说：Skyrizi的一家在哪里？顺便说一句，我能说这个吗？我刚才提到皮特·贾尔斯了。
J.B., you played golf with Gilesy before, over the years. The great Pete Giles. The great Pete Giles, and Sean, you know him very well. It just reminded me that any time he would get on the green, and sometimes some guys go, hey, because your ball is on the green, you're dancing, and he would, for years, say And you know, sometimes some guys go, hey, you know, cause your ball is on the green, you're dancing. And he would, for years say, you're Ted dancing.
J.B.，这些年来你跟贾尔斯一起打过高尔夫。伟大的皮特·贾尔斯。伟大的皮特·贾尔斯，肖恩，你很了解他。这让我想起，每当他上果岭时，有时有些人会说，嘿，因为你的球在果岭上了，你在跳舞，而他多年来一直会说——而且你知道，有时有些人会说，嘿，你知道的，因为你的球在果岭上了，你在跳舞。而他多年来一直会说，你就是特德·丹森（Ted Danson/dancing）。
For years, he would say, when your ball got on the green, you're Ted dancing. Yeah, one of my best friends of all time. Yeah, it just made me think of these guys. Cause the green's a dance floor. I know. Go for Sean Hayes. Yes, thank you.
多年来，他都会说，当你的球上了果岭，你就是在特德·丹森。对，我这辈子最好的朋友之一。对，这让我只想到了这些家伙。因为果岭就是舞池。我知道。为了肖恩·海斯。是的，谢谢。
Good story. You have this crazy ability. I know off the top of my head, all of the hit shows that you've been on. So you have this crazy ability to... Name them. You just said it. Okay, ready? No, you just fucking said it.
好故事。你有一种疯狂的能力。我脑子里能马上想出你演过的所有热门剧集。所以你有一种疯狂的能力去……说出它们的名字。你刚说过了。好吧，准备好了吗？不，你他妈刚说过了。
So no, name them. No, I said it. Well, obviously she shares Becker. I remember Becker. I remember, well, Good Place. I remember Creepshow. I remember CSI. you were on CSI. Which was very fun.
所以，不，说出它们的名字。不，我说过了。好吧，显然她分享了《贝克》（Becker）。我记得《贝克》。我记得，还有《善地》（The Good Place）。我记得《鬼作秀》（Creepshow）。我记得《犯罪现场调查》（CSI），你演过《CSI》。那非常有意思。
Damages. Damages, like you've done so many hit shows, it's unbelievable. By the way, I did audition for Ink, which was a short-lived sitcom, I did not get the part. Yeah, well, good for you. I heard the star didn't care for you. But how do you, is there a process by which you have
《裂痕》（Damages）。《裂痕》，你演过这么多热门剧集，简直难以置信。顺便说一句，我确实去为《墨水》（Ink）试镜过，那是一部寿命很短的情景喜剧，我没得到那个角色。好吧，那对你挺好。我听说那个明星不太看得上你。但是你是怎么做到的，有没有一个过程让你拥有
like a filtering system? A filtering system for how to pick the right project? Because you seem to always do that. The trick is to spend all your money, so you have to go to work. No, you know, oh, come on, I am here talking to you because of Les and Glenn Charles and Jimmy. That is literally why I'm here.
一个过滤系统？挑选正确项目的过滤系统？因为你似乎总能做到这一点。诀窍是花光你所有的钱，这样你就不得不去工作了。不，你知道的，噢，拜访吧，我坐在这里跟你说话是因为莱斯、格伦·查尔斯和吉米。这真的是我坐在这里的原因。
But then you pick massive hit shows. Well, people think... Well, the good writers tend to come your way because of Cheers. I mean, literally, I'm not playing Humble Pie. I'm here because of Cheers. And it was remarkable. I was talking to somebody who was going, we need to win the jackpot, you know?
但你随后挑选的都是超级热门剧集。好吧，人们以为……好吧，因为《干杯酒吧》（Cheers），优秀的编剧往往会主动来找你。我的意思是，真的，我不是在装谦虚。我能坐在这里是因为《Cheers》。这真的很了不起。我当时正在和某人聊天，那人说，我们需要中头奖，你知道吗？
And it was like, yeah, to tell the truth, I did win the jackpot. Playing Sam Malone on Cheers for 11 years is certainly a jackpot. But also, you know, the guys were talking about it earlier, you know, your vibe is, it is infectious, it does come through. You do have an ability to put your thing into whatever character you're playing,
就像是，是的，老实说，我确实中了大奖。在《Cheers》里扮演山姆·马隆11年绝对是个大奖。但同时，你知道的，刚才大家也在谈论，你知道的，你的氛围是，它是具有感染力的，它确实能传递出来。你确实有一种能力，把你的个人特色融入你所扮演的任何角色中，
even if it's a crabby character, which you play really well. There is a Ted Danson humanity that you're able to communicate to the audience, and it's just, it's great to be with and I'll bet it's great on set too. I'll bet that you in that leadership position create this environment where everybody kind of goes,
即使是个脾气暴躁的角色，而你把这类角色演得很好。有一种属于特德·丹森的人性，能够传达给观众，这感觉太棒了，而且我敢打赌在片场感觉也一定很棒。我敢打赌，你在那个领导岗位上营造了这样一种环境，让每个人都觉得，
oh, well maybe I should bring that part of me too and all of those things sort of add up and it becomes this really enjoyable thing to be a part of as a viewer. And I'll, you know, you're being very humble, but I'm sure that's a lot of the key to your success too, why every show works when you're a part of it. For sure.
哦，也许我也应该把我的那部分特质带进来，所有这些因素加起来，作为观众参与其中就会变成一件非常享受的事情。而且，你知道的，你表现得非常谦虚，但我确信这也是你成功的关键所在，为什么只要你参演每一部剧都能成功。肯定的。
Yeah, but I mean, no, I won't do Humble Pie, but you all know that it's the writing. I mean, yeah, you can be really good and interesting. But an asshole can fuck up good writing. Yes, that's true. Or you don't want to be around them. I do love going to work. I do love actors.
对，但我的意思是，不，我不会假谦虚，但你们都知道这是因为剧本。我是说，对，你可以又优秀又有趣。但混蛋也能把好剧本搞砸。是的，这倒没错。或者你根本不想跟他们待在一起。我确实热爱工作。我确实热爱演员。
I do love writers. I do love the whole process. I am as starry eyed as I was. I love going to Studio Gates and crossing over Jimmy Stewart Avenue and passing, you know. That's so good to hear. And working with that crew too.
我确实热爱编剧。我确实热爱整个过程。我依然像以前一样充满憧憬。我喜欢去制片厂大门，走过吉米·斯图尔特大道，经过，你知道的。很高兴听到这些。而且和那个剧组一起工作也是。
I mean, think about all those cameramen and Dolly Grips and they follow Jimmy around too and Jimmy, I mean, it's just a family that's. It is. It's a lot of. Yeah, it's a lot of. And also, it's also wonderful to be part of this tribe of funny.
我的意思是，想想所有的那些摄像师和拉焦员，他们也跟着吉米到处跑，而吉米，我的意思是，这就是一个大家庭。确实如此。有很多。是的，有很多。而且，能够成为这个喜剧部落的一员也很美妙。
I am not, you guys are really quick and really funny. You know, I'm not, I am not, you guys are really quick and really funny. You really truly are. If I have funny material, I will indeed be funny. But I don't have that thing that you guys have. But I am part of the tribe of funny, and it makes me so happy. You know, I got to shake hands and hug Mel Brooks. How fucking cool is that?
我不是，你们几个反应极快而且非常搞笑。你知道的，我不是，你们几个反应极快而且非常搞笑。你们真的是这样。如果我有搞笑的素材，我当然也会搞笑。但我没有你们那种天赋。不过我是喜剧部落的一员，这让我太高兴了。你知道的，我有幸和梅尔·布鲁克斯握手拥抱。这他妈有多酷啊？
I worked with Mary Tyler Moore. It's like, ah! Ted, Ted, I hate to break it to you, man. You're on the fucking Mount Rushmore, okay? So, I got a news slash for you. And there's no, and maybe it's because of Jimmy and the Charles brothers, but they wanted you for that same reason that you described before.
我和玛丽·泰勒·摩尔合作过。这感觉就像，啊！特德，特德，我真不想打击你，老兄。你可是登上了他妈的拉什莫尔山，好吗？所以，我有个新消息要告诉你。而且没有，也许是因为吉米和查尔斯兄弟，但他们找你就是为了你之前描述的那个原因。
They wanted you to be good and you were. You were so fucking great, man. And I wonder if you, when you come out of something like Cheers, I can't imagine, because, well, I can. When you have something that has such, where there's such great chemistry, and it really works, and the writing is really good, and the performers are really good, and you have a shorthand,
他们希望你表现好，而你也确实做到了。你他妈太棒了，老兄。我在想，当你从像《Cheers》这样的剧集中走出来时，我无法想象，因为，好吧，其实我可以。当你拥有这样一部作品，彼此有着如此棒的化学反应，而且效果真的很棒，剧本真的很棒，演员真的很棒，你们之间有着心照不宣的默契，
and you know when you're really dialed in, that is so fucking fun. And I've had a few of those moments, and one of them was really when I was the most dialed in and felt like I was in a work environment in that way, was working with that guy right there with JB, when we did Arrest Development. There were a few months in there in my life
而且你知道自己什么时候真正进入状态时，那真的他妈的太有趣了。我也有过几次那样的时刻，其中有一次我真正进入状态、并且觉得是以那种方式处于工作环境中的，就是跟眼前这家伙、跟J.B.一起工作，当时我们拍了《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）。我生命中有几个月的时间
where I was like, fucking fuck, we are dialed right now. This feels great. And it's hard, but you guys did that at a level for years. What's that like when you go from that and what's the morning after like? Is it like, when you ended up going and doing amazing things after, but I mean the morning after a show like Cheers,
当时我就觉得，他妈的，我们现在完全进入状态了。感觉太棒了。这很难，但你们当年连续多年都达到了这种水平。当你从那种状态中走出来时，那是怎样的感受？第二天早晨是什么样的？是不是就像，虽然你后来去拍了令人惊叹的作品，但我的意思是，经历像《Cheers》这样的剧集之后的第二天早晨，
what was that like? My technique, you know, I think I have a little bit of that, I don't know, my mother's spiritual, religious, whatever, you know, pride goeth before a fall and all of that, it does smack of false humility. Here's how I handled Cheers Passing. I fucked up my life so publicly and so thoroughly that the actual passing of Cheers was, oh, it's over? It was that kind of, so I don't really know.
那是什么感觉？我的技巧，你知道的，我觉得我有点那种，我不知道，我母亲那种精神上的、宗教上的、诸如此类的东西，骄傲必先灭亡之类的那一套，这确实有点虚伪谦逊的嫌疑。我是这样处理《Cheers》结束这件事的：我把自己的生活搞得一团糟，如此公开且彻底，以至于《Cheers》真正的结束反而变成了：哦，结束了？就是那种感觉，所以我其实不太清楚。
I was more focused on trying to be better, Ted. And that was preoccupying me more than the end of cheers. I see. Well, it sounds like your priorities were in check then. Yeah, and I really worked very hard on myself and I don't think Mary would have even been walking down the same hallway as me if I hadn't. I don't think she would have even seen me.
我当时更专注于努力变得更好，特德。这比《Cheers》的结束更让我操心。我明白了。好吧，听起来你当时把轻重缓急理清了。对，我真的对自己下了很大功夫，如果我没有那样做，玛丽甚至都不会跟我走同一条走廊。我想她甚至都不会注意到我。
But that's life, man. I mean, we all handle things differently. Look, I can admit there have been lots of situations in my own life where I haven't handled it the best have been lots of situations in my own life Where I haven't handled it the best way It doesn't mean that in the moment but over time where I've kind of acted out in certain ways that were not the best representation of me or the best version of me and and I've and I've
但这就是生活，老兄。我的意思是，我们处理事情的方式各不相同。听着，我可以承认，在我自己的生活中有很多情况下我并没有以最好的方式——在我自己的生活中有很多情况下我并没有以最好的方式处理事情。这并不意味着在当时，但在一段时间里，我曾以某些方式表现出叛逆，而那并不是我最好的代表或最好的版本，而且我——而且我
You know felt a lot of shame about that and I've been Beat myself up about it and stuff. And at the end of the day, it's just, that's life. We're all kind of dealing with it in the moment and figuring it out as we go. You find the lane by like hitting the guardrails on both sides. Yeah, yeah.
你知道的，为此感到非常羞愧，我也为此自我折磨过之类的。归根结底，这就是生活。我们在当下的那一刻都在应对着，边走边摸索。你通过撞击两边的护栏来找到正确的车道。对，对。
And if your intention is to wake up, then all these little wounds or whatever can, a godsend in a way. But then I would imagine that it was, cause me as well, you know, it sounds like really challenging things in personal life kind of were at the same time as really good things or important things in the professional life and how those can sometimes help one another or fight one another.
如果你的意图是觉醒，那么所有这些小伤口或诸如此类的事，在某种程度上都是天赐的礼物。但接着我就会想象，这曾是——因为对我来说也是，你知道的，听起来个人生活中的巨大挑战，和职业生活中的巨大成功或重要事情同时发生，而这些事情有时如何能够相互促进或相互对抗。
So then when the show ended, you were navigating a challenging time for yourself, question mark. And then what was then that probably was somewhat scary for you to no longer have this, this, this cocoon of the show and the family and routine. You got sort of a new version of yourself coming online internally and externally. What was the, was there a gap for the next kind of hammock pole, if you will, by with a job that, that sort of brought you back up again and matched the growth you were doing personally
所以当节目结束时，你正在经历个人生活中充满挑战的时期，问号。然后接下来——那对你来说可能有点可怕，不再拥有这种节目的茧、这种家庭和常规。你的内在和外在正迎来一个新版本的自我。当时的——是不是有一个过渡期，在等待下一个像这样的“吊床杆”？就是那种能让你重新振作起来、并与你在个人成长上取得的成功相匹配的工作
with the success professionally? Well, you know, it came, once again, I think I was just, I was really excited to discover who I am, you know, and stop being a liar and being emotionally, as you know, this is ongoing process, obviously, and stop being a liar and being emotionally as, you know, this is ongoing process, obviously, but as being emotionally mature for the first time in my life or trying to be.
以及职业上的成功？嗯，你知道的，它来了，再一次，我想我只是——我真的很兴奋去发现我是谁，你知道的，不再做一个骗子，并且在情感上——如你所知，这显然是一个持续的过程——不再做一个骗子，并且在情感上——如你所知，这显然是一个持续的过程——而是生平第一次在情感上变得成熟，或者努力去做到成熟。
I was fascinated. I had an amazing mentor. So that truly was what was preoccupying me. But then right away I got a, Sherri Lansing is actually responsible for Mary and I being together. It was a terrible movie, but we were both cast in it. And we both came to each other at the,
我当时着迷了。我有一位了不起的导师。所以那确实是我当时全神贯注的事。但紧接着我接到一个——雪莉·兰辛（Sherri Lansing）其实是促成我和玛丽在一起的幕后推人。那是一部糟糕的电影，但我们俩都被选上了。我们俩在——
she had just broken up from a four year relationship and was saying to friends, I know I look like I should be good at relationship, but I don't, I can't, I'm not. Obviously I'm not that person. I have two beautiful kids, I'll be good at relationship, but I don't, I can't, I'm not. Obviously I'm not that person. I have two beautiful kids, I'll leave it at that. I was going, well, truly you can fuck up any relationship and it's you, Ted, that's doing it,
她刚结束了一段四年的恋情，正对朋友们说，我知道我看起来应该很擅长处理恋情，但我不是，我做不到，我不会。显然我不是那种人。我有两个可爱的孩子，我应该擅长恋情，但我做不到，我不会。显然我不是那种人。我有两个可爱的孩子，我就说到这儿吧。我当时在想，真的，你搞砸任何恋情都轻而易举，而且问题在于你自己，特德，是你自己在搞砸，
so maybe you need to just not be in a relationship. And we met and we became friends, having declared to each other that same kind of feeling that we both had of being kind of flops at relationship and just fell head over, we fell head over heel, I'll speak for myself, in love and have been inseparable ever since. It's been one of the more successful Hollywood relationships
所以也许你根本不应该处于一段恋情中。然后我们相遇了，我们成为了朋友，彼此坦白了那种我们都有的、觉得自己简直就是恋爱白痴的感觉，然后我们就深深地——我只代表我自己——坠入爱河，从此形影不离。这是好莱坞最成功的恋情之一，
and how long has it been? It's the 29 of the more successful Hollywood relationships. I mean, how long has it been? It's the... 29 married, 31 together. I mean, that's incredible. No way. Yeah, that's amazing. Yeah. Wow.
持续多久了？这是——最成功的好莱坞恋情之一。我的意思是，持续多久了？这是——结婚29年，在一起31年。我的意思是，这太不可思议了。真的假的？对，这太惊人了。真的。哇。
Yeah. Yeah. I can't believe how much money I lost on that. Sorry. And I hate, I hate admitting it. No, but... But the odds were just, you couldn't avoid them, right, Will? Yeah, you couldn't.
对。对。我简直不敢相信我在那上面输了多少钱。抱歉。我讨厌，我讨厌承认这一点。不，但是……但这个概率简直是，你根本无法避开它们，对吧，威尔？对，你避不开。
I mean, look at that. She's so cute. This is yesterday. Mary on her screensaver. This is yesterday. Come on. That's so fucking great, dude. Yeah, that's why my life really works, truly.
我的意思是，看看这个。她太可爱了。这是昨天拍的。玛丽在她的屏幕保护程序上。这是昨天拍的。拜托。这他妈太棒了，老兄。对，这就是为什么我的生活真的很顺利，真的。
Yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Ted, you know what's so funny is we often ask people when they come on here, we're like, well, you've done this and what would you want to do? You've fucking done it all. You've done every genre.
对。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。我们马上回来。好了，回到节目中。特德，你知道最好笑的是什么吗？我们经常问那些来这里的嘉宾，我们会问，嗯，你已经做过这个了，那你还想做什么？你他妈什么都做过了。你尝试过所有类型。
You've done Broadway, you've done comedy, you've done drama, you've done film, you've done, like you've done, so I don't even know where to go with that. Like which one do you like? I want to keep trying to experience what it is to be funny or explore the human frailty or whatever you want to call it. It doesn't, it can be drama as long as it has wit, you know, and humor somewhere in there.
你演过百老汇，你演过喜剧，你演过正剧，你演过电影，你演过，你就像是什么都演过，所以我都不知道该怎么顺着这个问下去了。比如你最喜欢哪一种？我想继续尝试体验当喜剧演员是什么感觉，或者探索人性的脆弱，随便你怎么称呼它。它不——只要其中包含机智和幽默，它可以是正剧。
But I want to know what that's like at every age. I want to keep acting and I'm 77 in a few months. It's different, it's different. Trying to figure out how to be funny. You look amazing. Hey, you know what? We've been on this fucking podcast for like almost an hour and that's the first time anyone has said how good I look.
但我想知道在每个年龄段那种感觉是怎样的。我想继续演戏，再过几个月我就77岁了。感觉不一样了，完全不一样。试图弄清楚如何保持幽默。你看上去状态好极了。嘿，你知道吗？我们在这个狗屁播客里聊了差不多一个小时了，这是第一次有人说我看起来状态这么好。
You look great, and you are great, and what is it that you watch? Do you watch a lot of stuff? Do you devour other material too? Like what are the things that? Yeah, anything you're watching right now that's making you really laugh. Hey, all three of you may have made me laugh
你看起来棒极了，你本来就很棒，你平时都看些什么？你看很多作品吗？你也如饥似渴地看其他素材吗？比如都有哪些东西？对，你现在有什么正在看的东西能让你真的笑出来的？嘿，你们三个这些年来可能都让我
so much over the years, and you do have different styles. Not today. It is, but... What? Not today? Are you kidding me? You should have seen me while you all were bantering.
笑过无数次，而且你们确实有着不同的风格。今天可没有。确实是，但是……什么？今天没有？你在开玩笑吧？你们刚才在互相打趣的时候，要是看到我当时的表情就好了。
I was doing spit takes. They told me not to. Okay. You seem, you're so aware of sort of the, of bullshit, and you seem so, you seem so good about being not full of bullshit and being real, being honest with yourself. It seems like you really, or at least you really make me laugh when you play these characters that they act like they are smarter than they actually are.
我差点把水喷出来。他们告诉我别这样。好吧。你似乎，你对那些虚伪的东西有着极高的觉察力，你似乎很擅长——不虚伪、做自己、对自己诚实。看起来你真的——或者至少当你扮演那些假装自己比实际更聪明的角色时，真的把我逗笑了。
They act like they're- Damages to me was one of the funniest things I got to do. Because that's the epitome of that. Exactly, it's sort of behaving like you're more confident than you actually are because you are aware of how fragile confidence and intelligence really is. Because you're honest with yourself about that. Is that kind of accurate?
他们假装自己——对我来说，《裂痕》是我演过最有趣的事情之一。因为那是那种特质的化身。没错，这有点像表现得比实际更有自信，因为你很清楚自信和智慧实际上是多么脆弱。因为你对此对自己很诚实。这算准确吗？
You like playing those characters that kind of have this Like you like playing those characters that are, that kind of have this kind of thin veneer that you enjoy showing the audience kind of cracks in? Yeah, I love the silliness of men. I love being a silly man. Yeah, I love that too. And I would like to be, you know, it can be disguised, it can be, but you know, we're silly. We're silly creatures, and I love that.
你喜欢扮演那些具有——就像你喜欢扮演那些有这种薄薄的外表、并且你很乐意向观众展示其中的裂痕的角色？对，我喜欢男人的傻气。我喜欢做一个傻气的男人。对，我也喜欢这个。而且我想成为——你知道的，它可以是被伪装的，可以是被掩饰的，但你知道的，我们很傻。我们是傻气的生物，我喜欢这样。
Yeah, we're so flawed. Yeah, and I do love humor that comes out of sadness. I do love that. It's so much fucking suffering. And if you can find a way to laugh while acknowledging the sadnesses of life, that I am so happy when you get to do that. Well, then you're gonna die laughing
对，我们浑身都是缺点。对，我确实喜欢源于悲伤的幽默。我真的非常喜欢。这世上有这么多的痛苦。如果你能在承认生活悲伤的同时找到一种欢笑的方式，每当能做到这一点时，我都感到无比快乐。好吧，那你要是读了肖恩的维基百科页面，
if you read Sean's Wikipedia page. Hey listen. Wait a minute, Ted. I was looking through your earlier credits and I see that you did an episode of BJ and the Bear. That sounds like something right up my alley. Yes, no it's not, Sean, it's not. What are you talking about, BJ and the Bear?
你一定会笑死的。嘿，听着。等一下，特德。我刚才翻看你早期的演艺经历，我看到你演过一集《贝杰和熊》（BJ and the Bear）。听起来这非常对我的胃口。对，不，不是的，肖恩，根本不是。你在胡说些什么，什么《BJ and the Bear》？
No, no, no, it's not BJ with the Bear. No, it's BJ and. It's not BJ from a bear. No, no, no, it's not BJ with the bear. No, it's BJ and. It's not BJ from a bear. So. Um. So. Um. Um.
不，不，不，不是带着熊的BJ。不，是BJ and。不是从熊那里来的BJ。不，不，不，不是带着熊的BJ。不，是BJ and。不是从熊那里来的BJ。所以。嗯。所以。嗯。嗯。
Um. Um. Um. Um. Um. Um. Hey, you guys are like a basketball team of three-pointers. You know, one of the shooting guards gets hot
嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嘿，你们就像是一支全员能投三分球的篮球队。你知道的，其中一个得分后卫手感火热，
and the rest of you just sit along and let him run. Way to go, Ted. Now you got Sean thinking about a basketball team. Hey, listen. I... I... I... I...
而你们其他人就坐在旁边让他尽情发挥。干得好，特德。现在你让肖恩开始琢磨篮球队了。嘿，听着。我……我……我……我……
I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I...
我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……
I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I... I...'ll do anything. I really will, pretty much do anything.
我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……我……什么都愿意做。我真的愿意，几乎什么都愿意做。
You're so lucky you get to work so much in Los Angeles too, my God. I know, that is amazing. You know what I forgot about? You did those three men and a baby, right? Remember those? Yes, those are great. You must remember, you were in them.
你在洛杉矶能有这么多工作机会，简直太幸运了，天哪。我知道，那太棒了。你知道我忘了什么吗？你演过那部《三个奶爸一个娃》（Three Men and a Baby），对吧？还记得那些吗？是的，那些很棒。你一定记得，你就在里面演。
What was that? Huge success. Those were huge hits, right, Ted? I mean, one was, the other one the first one was like gangbusters I mean, I don't know. Yeah huge huge amount of millions and then the second one which was pretty well done And I remember having lunch with Jeffrey Katzenberg and saying because it was about to come out three men and a little lady And we're we're gonna do great. We are keeping our eye on this other show, kind of small show coming out called Home Alone,
那是什么？巨大的成功。那些都是大热门，对吧，特德？我的意思是，一部是，另一部——第一部简直火得一塌糊涂，我的意思是，我不知道。对，巨额的数额，几百万票房，然后第二部拍得也挺好。我记得我和杰弗里·卡 Katzenberg 吃午饭时说，因为当时《三个奶爸一个小天使》（Three Men and a Little Lady）快要上映了，
but I think we'll do great. You came out the same weekend? Yeah. Oh my God. Blew us out of the water. Wow. That was 1990 or something like that? Yeah.
我们觉得会大卖。我们正盯着另一部即将上映的小成本电影，叫《小鬼当家》（Home Alone），但我认为我们会大卖。你们是同一个周末上映的？对。哦，天哪。把我们打得落花流水。哇。那是1990年左右吗？对。
No. Oh my God. But those, I mean, those were, what was the biggest, what was the hardest part on those movies? Because you're working with a baby. Was it working with a baby or waiting for Tom Selleck to glue on his mustache? Because I would imagine.
不。哦，天哪。但这些，我的意思是，那些——拍那些电影时最难的部分是什么？因为你要跟一个婴儿合作。是跟婴儿合作，还是等汤姆·塞莱克（Tom Selleck）把他的胡子粘上去？因为我猜……
No, leave that man alone. He's one of my favorites. I'm kidding, I'm kidding. I love the guy. Are you kidding? I love him, I'm joking. He's one of the true gentlemen in our business. Of course.
不，别去招惹那个人。他可是我的最爱之一。开玩笑的，开玩笑的。我爱死这家伙了。开玩笑吧？我爱他，我开玩笑的。他是我们这行真正的绅士之一。当然。
I've never heard a bad thing about him. Same. No. That's why I made they. He's one of the true gentlemen in our business. Of course. I've never heard a bad thing about him. Same. No. That's why I made the joke. He's great. If he sucked, I wouldn't. He's incredible. I, Magnum P.I. for me was the fucking greatest. But was-
我从来没听过关于他的半句坏话。我也是。没有。所以我才开玩笑的。他太棒了。如果他很烂，我就不会了。他太不可思议了。《夏威夷神探》（Magnum P.I.）对老子来说简直是太棒了。但是——
I lost the job due to, due to Magnum P.I. The first year of Magnum, I played a murderous schmuck husband who's getting the shit beat out of him on a boat by Tom Selleck. And it was the first time I realized I had a big ball spot on the back of my head, because there was an overhead shot of, you know,
我因为《夏威夷神探》而失去了那份工作。在《夏威夷神探》的第一年，我扮演一个暴躁无能的丈夫，在一条船上被汤姆·塞莱克痛扁。那是第一次我意识到自己后脑勺有个很大的秃斑，因为有一个俯拍镜头，你知道的，
this incredible Hulk of a man, handsome guy, beating the shit out of this wimpy, murderous husband with the ball spot. And I swear to God, this is true. Please, Steven Spielberg listens to your show, I'm sure. Oh, a lot. But my version of, and I hope it's true, was he was talking to me about poltergeist.
这个身材魁梧、长相帅气的男子汉，正在痛扁这个带着秃斑、懦弱又暴躁的丈夫。我向上帝发誓，这是真的。拜访吧，史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格肯定听你们的节目。哦，听得可多了。但我的版本是——我希望这是真的——他当时正在跟我谈论《鬼驱人》（Poltergeist）。
Then he happened to, within a week or two, see the Magnum PI episode, and I heard he was no longer interested. And... Well, but then he hires Craig T. Nelson, who's no Sasquatch, you know? Pfft! I mean, God bless.
然后他碰巧在一两周内看到了那集《夏威夷神探》，我听说他对我就不再感兴趣了。而且……好吧，但后来他雇用了克雷格·T·纳尔逊（Craig T. Nelson），他可不是什么大脚怪（Sasquatch），对吧？呸！我的意思是，上帝保佑。
Yes, you're right, you're right. He was thinning, he was thinning, yeah. Yeah. So maybe I made that up. Maybe I'm wrong. Maybe he just didn't like my work that could well be I just like the no Sasquatch as well It's not like a turn people you hey look at this guy he's no Sasquatch
是的，你说得对，你说得对。他当时头发也在变稀疏，他在变稀疏，对。所以也许我是瞎编的。也许我弄错了。也许他只是不喜欢我的表演，那很有可能。我只是喜欢那个“他可不是什么大脚怪”的梗。这听起来不像是在贬低人，嘿，你瞧这家伙，他可不是什么大脚怪。
Well, I'm just auditioning it Keep it wait wait Ted before we let you go. No, I'm on a roll, I don't want to go. No, you don't have to go, please, we love having you. What was the last, do you remember the last audition you had? It had to have been pre-chairs.
好吧，我只是在试探着说。保持——等等，等等，特德，在我们让你走之前——不，我正渐入佳境呢，我不想走。不，你不用走，求你了，我们太喜欢你留在这里了。上一次——你还记得你上一次试镜是什么时候吗？那肯定是在《Cheers》之前。
It was probably for a feature, I think it was probably, it was a really funny movie, the first 10 minutes didn't work and then it just took off. I think it was ended up coming out called The Amateurs. It was called The Moguls for a while. It was Jeff Bridges in the small town and he decides the only way to put the town on the map is for them to do the whole town to participate in an amateur porn.
那可能是一部电影，我想大概是——那是一部非常搞笑的电影，前10分钟没拍好，然后就渐入佳境了。我想最后上映时叫《业余选手》（The Amateurs）。有一段时间叫《大人物》（The Moguls）。杰夫·布里吉斯（Jeff Bridges）在一个小镇里，他决定让小镇名声大噪的唯一方法，就是让全镇居民都参与拍摄一部业余色情片。
And that was going gonna put us all, you probably didn't see it, it's really kind of wonderful. But I auditioned for that. I feel like the last audition I had was Hudsucker Proxy, Phone Brothers film. Oh, I remember. Really? I bet it wasn't the last one I did, but it was the last one I really remember
那会让我们所有人都——你可能没看过，它其实挺奇妙的。但我为那个去试镜了。我觉得我最后一次试镜是科恩兄弟的电影《影子大亨》（The Hudsucker Proxy）。哦，我记得。真的吗？我敢说那不是我做的最后一次，但这是我真正记得的最后一次，
because boy, I wanted that bad. I don't think auditions are bad though, because don't you want to make sure you're right for the part? Yes, I say that all the time. You get an offer, and then the first time anyone sees your plan for the character is right before you shoot it,
因为天哪，我太想要那个角色了。不过我不认为试镜是件坏事，因为难道你不想确保自己适合这个角色吗？对，我经常这么说。如果你直接拿到角色邀约，然后大家第一次看到你对这个角色的设想，居然是在即将开拍之前，
while you're rehearsing the scene, and you can take a big swing, and they go, you can hear the silence, and there's no time to recast you, or to give you a note to put you on a different track. It's tough, yeah. Yeah, Sean, last audition, do you remember? Uh-oh.
也就是在排练这场戏的时候，你可以放手一搏，然后他们——你能听到一片沉默，根本没有时间重新选角，也没有时间给你提出意见让你改走别的路线。这确实很难，对吧。对，肖恩，你最后一次试镜是什么时候，你还记得吗？噢哦。
I don't know, some Jake Gyllenhaal movie years and years and years ago. I can't remember. Wow, doesn't it? Yeah, Willie? I feel like there's a BJ and a bear joke coming in here, so. No, no, no, that was an offer.
我不知道，好多年好多年以前某部杰克·吉伦哈尔（Jake Gyllenhaal）的电影吧。记不清了。哇，是不是？对，威尔？我觉得有关于《BJ and the Bear》的笑话要来了，所以。不，不，不，那是一个邀约。
I mean, I think it was. I mean, it was, because it was through a bush. It was through a bush and it was just, hey. Just a bunch of cash and a low voice. And they hand the papers through the bush, through the bushes. You got to have an answer. Come on, what's the answer? No, I know, I know. I'm just trying to think what it was.
我的意思是，我想是的。我的意思是，它是，因为它是通过灌木丛递过来的。它是通过灌木丛递过来的，然后就是，嘿。只有一堆现金和一个低沉的声音。他们把文件通过灌木丛、从灌木丛里递过来。你得有个答案。快点，答案是什么？不，我知道，我知道。我只是在想要是什么。
I think I... How about Arrested Development? That audition was great, I was with Tony Hale and you, last one, we were all in the room together, you, me, crushed it. Jason, you auditioned for that too. I just kind of assumed it was you and yours. No, no, no, I auditioned hard for that one.
我想我……《发展受阻》怎么样？那次试镜太棒了，我和托尼·海尔（Tony Hale）还有你，最后一次，我们都在同一个房间里，你、我，表现炸裂。杰森，你当时也去试镜了。我一直以为那是直接找你的。不，不，不，我为那个拼命试镜过。
I was very surprised I got an audition for that. But the only reason Mitch Hurwitz read me for that is because he remembered me from auditioning for some pilot like a few years earlier that I didn't get, but he remember liking me for. Wasn't it the hockey one? Perhaps, I'm not sure, but boy, that show saved my life. You all have made me, I get to say this, don't cut it,
我很惊讶自己能得到那个试镜机会。但米奇·赫维茨（Mitch Hurwitz）让我读剧本的唯一原因，是因为他记得几年前我曾为某个试镜过但没拿下的试镜表现得不错，他记得当时挺喜欢我的。难道是那个冰球题材的？也许吧，我不确定，但天哪，那部剧救了我的命。你们真的让我——我得说这个，可别把它剪掉——
have made me laugh so hard, not only today, but in everything you've done over the years. That got you, Ted. Likewise. Such a joy to sit in the. And a lot this hour, too. Thank you so, so, so much. Thanks for being here, Ted.
把我逗得前仰后合，不仅是今天，还有你们这些年来做过的所有作品。这可拿捏住你了，特德。彼此彼此。能坐在这儿真是太——而且这一个小时里也笑了很多次。非常非常非常感谢。谢谢你能来，特德。
I appreciate it. Ted, I'm going to say this, and I don't throw this term around lately. You know, it's coming your way, you know? What are you going to say? Say, you're a world-class jerk-off. No, I'm not going to say that. I'm going to say, you're a fucking national hero. You really are. You really are, dude.
我很感激。特德，我要说这个，我平时可不轻易用这个词。你知道它要来了，你知道吧？你要说什么？说你是个世界级的混蛋。不，我才不说那个。我要说的是，你他妈就是个民族英雄。真的。你真的是，老兄。
You are a treasure. And I just couldn't think any more highly of you. I just think that you're a great guy and you're so great at what you do for so long. And keep doing it. And I'm glad you're doing a show with the great Mike Schur, whom we adore and is an unbelievable talent in his own right. And just thanks for doing this, man.
你是个国宝。我对你的评价再高也不为过。我只觉得你是个大好人，而且你长期以来一直把工作做得这么出色。继续保持下去。我很高兴你跟伟大的迈克·舒尔（Mike Schur）一起合作一档节目，我们非常崇拜他，他本身就是一个难以置信的天才。谢谢你做这一切，老兄。
It's what a thrill to be able to sit here with you and talk to you. Honestly, it's just an absolute thrill for me, so thank you. Podcasts are cool, man. Podcasts are cool. Thank you for showing us the way. And congrats on yours. Yeah, I can't wait to listen to that.
能坐在这里跟你一起聊天简直太让人兴奋了。老实说，对我来说这绝对是莫大的刺激，所以谢谢你。播客太酷了，老兄。播客太酷了。谢谢你为我们指明道路。也祝贺你的播客开播。对，我等不及要听了。
Yeah, by the way, yeah, you and Woody, you and Woody, it turns out you got good chemistry. Yeah. Yeah, because he's so, I'm the straight guy and he's just all over the map. He's such a... Love him. I love him so much. I do too.
对，顺便说一句，你和伍迪，你和伍迪，事实证明你们俩化学反应很好。对。对，因为他太——我是正经人，而他思维天马行空。他简直是个——爱死他了。我太爱他了。我也是。
Just quickly, and then we'll go goodbye. My favorite is Woody's during Cheers. If you were 15 minutes late, it was okay. If you're a half hour late, hey, we're, by 45 minutes late, people get pissed, and it was about 45 minutes late, no Woody. Somebody comes running in and said, oh, I forgot to tell you, Woody is in Berlin.
简单说一下，然后我们就该说再见了。我最喜欢的是伍迪在拍《Cheers》期间的事。如果你迟到15分钟，没关系。如果你迟到半小时，嘿，我们在呢，到了迟到45分钟，大家就开始生气了，而当时已经迟到45分钟了，还不见伍迪人影。有人跑进来说，哦，我忘告诉你们了，伍迪在柏林。
The wall is coming down and he didn't want to miss it. Oh my God. Literally. No way. The Floyd show, yeah. No way. Good for him. He was like, fuck it, I'm not missing this.
柏林墙倒塌了，他不想错过。哦，天哪。真的假的。没门。弗洛伊德的演出，对。不可能。真有他的。他当时的想法是：操，我可不能错过这个。
It must have been wild, Ted, to watch the evolution of Woody Harrelson from getting the part and starting out at the end of the series to what he had become as a human being and as an activist and as everything, as a movie star. And he's a wonderful actor. I love him. He sure is.
看着伍迪·哈里森（Woody Harrelson）从刚得到角色、刚开始演剧集，到后来作为一个人、作为一个人权活动家、作为一切、作为电影巨星的演变，特德，那一定很疯狂吧。而且他是个出色的演员。我爱他。他确实是。
And the more popular, or if he gets nominated, my little revenge is to watch his film on my cell phone. Yeah. Just a big movie star. Hey, I'm his film on my cell phone. You know, just a big movie star. Hey, I'm watching you on my cell phone. That's great. I love that. Anyway, Teddy, we love you.
而且他越受欢迎，或者如果他获得提名，我的小小的报复就是在我的手机上观看他的电影。对。就是一个大电影明星。嘿，我在手机上看着你的电影呢。太棒了。我喜欢这样。不管怎样，特德，我们爱你。
Love you, enjoy the rest of your trip over there. Thank you for doing this a lot. Get rest, good luck with your film. Oh, you woke me up. This hour did wonders for me. Thank you so much. You did. Thank you.
爱你，好好享受你在那儿剩下的旅程。非常感谢你来做客。去休息吧，祝你的电影好运。哦，你把我唤醒了。这一个小时对我的帮助太大了。非常感谢。你真的做到了。谢谢。
Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye. Well, he just lifted me up. I was just gonna say, God, I love that guy's vibe. I mean. Something else, huh? Easy breezy, easy like summer morning. I'd love to work, I don't think he and I
拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。天哪，他简直让我整个人都振奋了。我刚想说，天哪，我太喜欢这家伙的氛围了。我的意思是。真是个奇人，对吧？轻松惬意，就像夏日清晨一样轻松。我很想合作——我不觉得他和我有过
have ever worked together. I'd love to work with him. Says a lot about you. Well, but I mean, it seems like. No, just that you're not sure is what it is. Well, but I mean, it seems like- No, just that you don't, you're not sure is what is going on right now. Well, but I guess what I'm saying is that we've had so many years in television,
任何合作。我很想跟他合作。这很能说明问题。好吧，但我的意思是，似乎——不，只是你不确定到底是怎么回事。好吧，但我的意思是——不，只是你——你现在还不确定到底发生了什么。好吧，但我的意思是，我们在电视圈待了这么多年，
I bet you we've been part of the same sort of like- Up friends. Yeah, or like charity, you know, kind of a telethon or whatever the fuck, you know? I do think it's funny, I do think it's a very funny thing in this town where, I won't say who it is, but I ran into a person that is known in the world, and she said-
我敢打赌我们一定参加过那种——比如同一拨朋友。对，或者是那种慈善活动，你知道的，电视募捐什么的，管他妈的是什么呢，你知道吗？我觉得挺好笑的，我觉得在这个圈子里有一件非常搞笑的事，我不说是谁，但我遇到了一位在世人眼里很有名的人，她说——
Male or female, because I'll guess it. Female, and she said- I've got it. I said, hey, I said, what's going on? She's like, have you ever been to her house? And it's like, if anybody from Chicago, where I'm from, you know who's been inside of your house. But I don't know, I disagree with that.
男的还是女的，因为我要猜一下。女的，她说——我懂了。我说，嘿，我说，怎么回事？她说：你去过她家吗？这就好比，如果任何来自芝加哥（我老家）的人，你都会知道谁去过你家里面。但我不知道，我不同意这一点。
I've said a million times to people coming over, although I'm not much of a barometer, but I'll be surprised. I'll say like, have you not been over before? Because if I've been friends with somebody for a long time, you forget whether you're over at your house or my house, you know? Because if I've been friends with somebody for a long time, you forget whether, you know, you're like over your house or my house, you just like assume. I don't know.
我曾对来访的人说过一百万遍了，虽然我不太适合做这种风向标，但我会感到惊讶。我会说，比如：你以前没来过吗？因为如果我和某人做了很久的朋友，你就会忘记你到底是在你家还是在我家，你知道吗？因为如果我和某人做了很久的朋友，你就会忘记——你知道的，你就像是在你家还是在我家，你只会这么觉得。我不知道。
Anyway, Teddy. Teddy's great. Teddy is the greatest. Teddy's great. Teddy's great. Will, nice guest. He's so great. And yeah, and you know, Ted and Woody have their podcast,
不管怎样，泰迪。泰迪太棒了。泰迪是最棒的。泰迪太棒了。泰迪太棒了。威尔，不错的嘉宾。他太棒了。而且，你知道，特德和伍迪有他们自己的播客，
which he was alluding to, that I did the first episode of. Yes, that's very nice. By the way, now I'm taking credit. Like I was on the, I didn't even know. Yeah, well, you launched it. Yeah. I launched the show that I did the first episode of. Yes, that's very nice. By the way, now I'm taking credit. Like I was on the, I didn't even know. Yeah, well you launched it. Yeah. That I launched the show that I launched. That they're doing is also on Sirius like us.
就是他刚才暗示的那档节目，我还去录了第一期呢。对，那太好了。顺便说一句，现在我在邀功了。就好像我是——我甚至都不知道。对，好吧，你启动了它。对。我启动了这个节目，我录了第一期。对，那太好了。顺便说一句，现在我在邀功了。就好像我是——我甚至都不知道。对，好吧，你启动了它。对。我启动了我启动的那个节目。他们正在做的那个节目也和我们一样在Sirius上播出。
Yeah, we are now on Sirius. We're all under the nice, beautiful roof of Sirius. Yeah. SiriusXM. So check it out. It's called Everybody Knows Your Name. Which is, I guess, an allusion to- Which is a nod to the song.
对，我们现在在Sirius上了。我们都在Sirius美丽可爱的屋檐下。对。SiriusXM。所以去听听吧。节目叫《Everybody Knows Your Name》。这名字我想是指——指的是那首歌。
Alluding to something. The song, the song, the Cheers song. I know, Sean. The theme song. I got it. Making a joke, you stupid-ass. Right now I want to go where nobody knows my name after that. Anyway.
暗示了什么。那首歌，那首歌，就是《Cheers》的主题曲。我知道，肖恩。主题曲。我懂。开个玩笑，你这个蠢货——在这之后，我现在只想去一个没人知道我名字的地方。不管怎样。
I was looking at a lot of- Here we go. Fucking here we go. I was looking at a lot of here we go fucking here Before you get into it, can I just say this? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's so even if we haven't done a show in a couple weeks Go ahead You can see you come across the street I can see the ramp up Yeah, I can see you know, you know can see, you know when a soccer player gets ready to take a penalty kick? All the time, yeah.
我当时在看很多——开始了。他妈的开始了。我在看很多——开始了，他妈的开始——在你切入正题之前，我能说这个吗？行。行。行。所以即使我们已经有几周没做节目了……说吧。你可以看到……你穿过街道，我能看到你情绪高涨。对，我能看出……你知道，你知道吗……就像足球运动员准备罚点球时那样？经常这样，对。
And they do that thing, they little sort of stutter step before they get a good, but I can see you doing your little stutter step. I can hear your engines rev up, like a semi trucker. Zzzz. Anyway, I was looking at his resume. You were looking at Ted's credits. You're looking at Ted's credits. I was looking at Ted's credits.
他们会做那种动作，在真正起脚前会来个小碎步，但我能看到你在做你的小碎步。我能听到你的引擎在轰鸣，就像个开半挂卡车的人。嗡嗡。不管怎样，我当时在看他的简历。你在看泰德的演艺经历。你在看泰德的演艺经历。我当时在看泰德的演艺经历。
And I was like, well, and you tell me, you stop me when you hear something that you might want to know more about, all right? He was on Help Me Help You, I remember that show. He was on Heist for two episodes. He was on something called Bye Bye Benjamin. Then he was on Knights of the South Bronx. And then our, was there one in there you wanna know about?
然后我想，好吧，你告诉我，当你听到可能想了解更多的事情时就打断我，好吗？他演过《帮助我帮助你》，我记得那个节目。他演过两集《银行大劫案》。他演过一部叫《拜拜，本杰明》的东西。然后他演了《南布朗克斯骑士》。然后我们……里面有什么你想了解的吗？
Well, tell me more about Bye Bye Benjamin. Oh yeah, that's the one. That was the worst? What's it called? Still rolling, you wanna go back to one? Do you want one more shot at that one? It's called Bye, Bye Benjamin. When you got to that title, you should have just hit it.
好吧，跟我多讲讲《拜拜，本杰明》。哦对，就是这个。那是演得最烂的吗？叫什么来着？还在录，你想倒回重来吗？你想再试一次吗？它叫《拜拜，本杰明》。当你念到这个名字时，你本来应该直接切入正题的。
I know, I was setting you up as a courtesy. What is happening? Do we need to send somebody over to the house to do like a fucking wellness check on you? What is happening? What's wrong with you? Alright, there's a show called Help Me Help You, and then you did Heist, and then you did a show called Bye Bye Benjamin! Why does it always need to go up into an octave that has never been established by any bird
我知道，我出于礼貌在给你铺垫。这到底怎么回事？我们需要派个人去你家做个什么狗屁健康检查吗？这到底怎么回事？你怎么了？好吧，有个节目叫《帮助我帮助你》，然后你演了《银行大劫案》，然后你演了一个叫《拜拜，本杰明！》的节目！为什么每次声音都要飙到一个任何鸟类都从没达到过的八度，
or... Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
或者……聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barberko. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝顶。《SmartLess》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆贾夫和本内特·巴尔贝科100%有机且手工制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。